Good morning I guess you couldn't faint in foil
I'll have PNG, the best I got is a JPEG.
I'm fucking typed in 10-4, I'll have PNG.
And again, none of them were PNGs.
So I'm fucking have this on my head.
Hold on, I need to re-calibrate.
Okay, there we go, I re-calibrated.
I'm freaking spinning off my head.
Shit, I did not filter through transparent images.
I absolutely did not.
I think I got to the eighth one and I was like,
you know what, I like this one
because the top part, the top part of the tin foil.
It looks so good.
And I was like, I want this.
So, I'll give myself the hiccups.
Right, no hiccups, because it's gonna hurt.
Okay, it's so funny considering the background, literally.
Right, I don't want the hiccups
because it's gonna really hurt.
This too was a high-table plot, literally me.
I don't know, I had a tin foil PNG like the other day.
Levy Exodus, thank you for becoming a member.
I appreciate it.
What kind of membership streams do I make?
In general, you're asking.
I usually stream three to four membership streams a week.
Are you squidding me right now?
But I have to...
Did some reeflings miss?
You got some white in your hair.
No, it's a PNG on purpose.
It's not a PNG by accident.
Are you squidding me right now?
A JPEG on purpose.
Mm!
I'm gonna go, Brian doesn't read out,
but I'll read out, don't worry.
Spidey, thank you for the tip.
I appreciate it.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon, reeflings.
Akadea says,
love, love, please take care of yourself.
Greetings from Germany.
Hello, Leute, Dankeschön.
Bitte, for das,
a membership einen Month.
Dankeschön.
It's the best I've got, I'm sorry.
Any German people listening?
I feel like the crying women mean,
babe, just go to sleep, you don't need a streamer.
I'm okay.
So basically, I'm gonna do a little yapping,
but thank you so much to everyone who has reached out.
Management basically got like,
six more clippers on board, which is perfect.
So I was up, kinda organizing a lot of clipping stuff.
I was doing a lot of liaison stuff.
Back and forth.
If you didn't know, the girls have got
GamerSupps codes.
Everyone's descriptions are getting updated incredibly shortly,
but you can just use the girls' names, GamerSupps.
For 10% off and any earnings fully,
go to the girl, Vehler, do not take a cut.
No, no, no, no, Vehler, don't touch none of that.
All profits, all for them.
There will be a few tweets coming out
that the girls will interact with,
just to really solidify.
And then, yeah, I do apologize for yawning.
Vehler, GamerSupps, yes.
I did not yet ask permission,
if I'm allowed to talk about certain things yet,
so you're gonna have to forgive me,
but I can talk about something further
if I am giving it all clear.
Same applies to you, yes, CodeStrony at checkout.
Gives you 10% off and it gives me a kickback.
And I believe I'm gonna get a PR package,
so you might get a hand cam stream of me snorting it.
That's terrible, do not, no, I'm not actually.
GamerSupps already is huge.
Yes, they were incredibly kind.
I can talk a bit more once I get the green light
about a certain thing I would like to attempt,
but can't do that yet.
Time to get your anime thighs
or teddy milk sponsored by Vehler.
Well, there's a new flavor coming out on GamerSupps.
It might already be out and it's called anime thighs
and you might recognize someone's thighs on it.
It's not my thighs, no, someone else's thighs.
So, you know, if you were curious,
you might recognize someone's thighs on the packaging.
If it's already out, if it's not out, do not listen to me.
I think it's already out
because they gave us promotional artwork for it.
It's not Warmelon, no, it's not me, it's not my thighs.
Someone else's thighs of Vehler.
Peeler flavor when?
It's orange.
But yes, I do apologize if I'm a little sleepyhead today.
So, I just wanna say, if any of you make War Thunder videos,
my dad was watching you bomb things in War Thunder.
Pearly, thank you for the five gifted members
and congrats to those who cut them with their face.
I apologize for her squint, my hat,
my little tinfoil hat is horizontal.
That thing is spinning on an axis, that's terrible.
Yeah, he was watching War Thunder videos.
So, if you make War Thunder videos,
there's a chance my dad watched you.
We were also watching Australian car crashes,
and compilations, War Hammer, War Thunder.
War Thunder with the planes, my dad has planes.
He loves planes.
War Thunder leaked more documents again.
Honestly, that's hilarious.
It's actually my dad's, sorry, sorry, my dad's at it again.
I apologize, he just gets a bit overzealous
about the details on the planes and stuff.
You know, they have to be right, they have to be accurate.
And is he into the War Thunder Kiss Me loop?
No, he's into the let's test out nuclear bombs
and what happens when we drop them loop.
We were literally watching nuclear bombs
get dropped in the game, and I was like, oh yeah, curious.
And like honestly, the stuff my dad watches is hilarious.
So one minute we're watching nuclear bombs,
next minute we're watching car crash compilations
from Australia, because everyone's like, oh, you effing suit.
Like every time there's a crash.
And then we jumped over to the chef, what's his name?
The French Italian chef, it's like Jean Pierre or something.
And he goes, onion.
And we were like jumping between all these categories.
It was, I was getting flat, like, not flashbacks.
I was getting whipped around, honestly.
10 file foil hat, absolutely.
We're playing a game called Orwell.
If you didn't know, 1984 is a book by George Orwell.
And it's about how everything is in shambles, okay?
And we're about to play a game based on it.
Now, this is my only concern,
because I have not slept properly, Jean Pierre.
Ah, it's like a chef that's French and Italian.
The surveillance state, basically.
Because I've not slept, I don't know if my reading skills
are gonna be down dramatically.
Thank you again, Pearlie, for those gifted subs.
I appreciate you.
I actually need to check if I have any more emotes slots.
I might actually have more unlocked.
Just like real life.
Exactly, Reefling.
What's that about the high table?
Sean, you're gonna be so cooked on this one, honestly.
Right, so we're just gonna get into it.
It's a bit of a reading simulator,
but please don't worry, I'll read.
Please do tell me if the music's too loud
or anything over my life.
Don't record yourself peeing literally in 1984.
Okay, that's when you're allowed to be mad, so.
We're just starting a fresh, clean game.
We'll go from the start.
Is this game about surveillance?
That is, congratulations.
You've been selected for the Orwell test base.
Please create a profile, enter your name.
Big G, E, you know what, I'll put Reefling.
Reefling, next step.
Please choose a profile picture.
Reefling, what do you look like?
I guess that guy.
Are you old?
No, that's an OG, son.
Oh, this is like really weird.
Yeah, I guess that's you, Reefling.
Let's go.
Is that a joke?
Oh, it's not a joke.
Okay, let's say, can I just play the game?
Wait, oh, come on, that's a bit ironic.
Okay, that one was a bit ironic.
What the fuck was that?
No, the neck bear reddit mod, the old lady.
Shawnee, when do you have to make you do a sleep stream
just so we could finally, oh, honestly.
Please agree to the following terms.
I am aware my actions will severely impact
the lives of the citizens of the nation.
I will work thoroughly and judge objectively
to the best of my belief.
While working, I will adhere to the law and jurisdiction.
Yeah, sure, sure.
Setting up pro.
For ensuring the safety, thank you,
for ensuring the safety of the nation's people.
Your registration is now complete.
Please wait, logging in.
Freedom Plaza.
I would do a sleep and stream, but afar in my sleep.
Oh, my God, we're losing 1,000 social credit right now
in China, for even acknowledging the system.
Mummy, about to come to CIA, agent's best friend
exposed to all our degeneracy.
Enemy spotted.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, OK.
Oh, right, OK.
On a bus?
15 social credit purchasing,
being chilling ice cream is not illegal.
We're done for.
I completely forgot how this game.
I thought it was a text-based simulator.
Whoa, that's bright.
The clocks were striking 13.
That's not possible.
Eh, Symes, you're online.
Good.
Call me Symes.
I'll be your advisor on Orwell.
Together, we will form both the first and the last line
of defence against terrorism.
For the test phase, you are one of the first people
to try out the Orwell system under real circumstances.
Nothing happened.
Everything's normal, citizens.
Go back home.
Selected from thousands of applicants from across the globe.
Oh, and you picked me of all people with the tinfoil hat on.
I bet you did.
Normally, congratulations would be in order,
but as you can see from that footage,
there has been an incident.
So let's get started.
I've activated the reader tool for you.
Its purpose is storing bookmarks to online websites
and documents for easy access and to highlight
when there is new info to be investigated.
First, I want you to be informed of the situation.
Our leading newspaper, The National Beholder,
will bring you up to speed.
HR a bit lacking to be fair.
I feel like this game is about to have so many triggers.
All right, headlines.
Let's see what the headlines are loading.
So, Bomba obliterates freedom memorial and kills three.
Feel free to browse The National Beholder.
I've activated the pro-filer.
Open the unknown person's file case once you're done.
Nations in tri-filth, what?
Tri-filth failed?
Pay par...
Oh my God, I can't even read it all.
Par-gay-cyan.
Par-guess-ian.
President.
Aborts negotiations with opposition.
Violent riots in tri-filth.
Blaine encourages renewal.
Jeez, Louise.
Hey, Stormy.
I'm just coming from Sheevee's Twitter space.
It was really fun.
She highly recommends it.
What?
I'm using it.
Maybe shoot complete.
So, what does it say?
Proximately Wednesday evening, a device popped its clogs.
According to the official police reports, three folk were killed
and at least five bystanders were severely wounded.
The freedom memorial was nearly completely destroyed.
Police closed off the area.
Prime Minister Blaine immediately issued a press statement
and put the nation on high alert.
Study with the future.
She was using Twitter space to read miles.
Parmesan President.
President Cheese.
Unknown person.
Date birth address.
Oh, okay.
The profile holds all known information on those we investigate.
The profile you've offered does our main suspect.
The blue-haired woman that the CCTV footage shows before the assault
is no stranger to the police.
Take a look at their arrest record.
Yes, I will take a look at the arrest record.
Where is it?
I'm clicking.
I don't want that to...
Um...
The arrest record.
I know exactly where that is.
Yes.
Yep.
Okay.
Log out.
Nope.
Don't close.
Right.
Hold on.
We're having a few issues.
Okay.
Watergate.
Watergate Cassandra.
The highlighted elements in the records are pieces of data that are able to be extracted.
We call these elements data chunks.
Hovering over data chunks will reveal their relevance to the case
and any connections or information it may influence.
Drop and drag all data chunks from the police database
into a profile to upload them to our servers.
So, Watergate Cassandra is a name.
So, we upload her name.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, her name's Cassandra.
Arrest date doesn't...
Suspect was arrested on site.
I don't see any other data chunk.
Oh, I guess her picture.
Sorry.
Of course, she has blue hair and pronouns.
Wait, unironically does she?
Very good.
Enter the names or critical information for Orwell to study a person and identify.
Information and documents can only become a data chunk
when it is clearly been assigned to a targeted person.
Add the reason for Miss Watergate's prior arrest has just been unlocked.
We will need this info to progress.
So, she did assault on a police officer.
I came...
Where is my complimentary FBI hat?
No, no, no.
We're tinfoil here.
We're tinfoil gang.
With the data you extracted from the police record,
a new document can now be assessed.
Now, let me ask you a question.
Do you believe in coincidences?
I do not.
Find data revealing where she attacked the police officer
and you will see what I mean.
Okay, what?
Suspect was arrested on site after Officer Franklin
had been struck by an unknown object
and became unresponsive.
The protestor at the origin of the assault
was forcefully removed with the suspect
who saw kneeling and weeping on the ground.
When asked to lay on the ground with her hands behind her back,
the suspect cooperated immediately.
Wait, so she paid attention right away?
Why was she greeting?
Coincidence, I think.
No, yeah, why was she greeting?
Guess what, I don't know.
I'm not really sure.
Is this woman a terrorist?
Whoa, they're already printing it?
Women allegedly injured a police officer
two weeks ago remains in custody,
trial scheduled for August.
Wait, that's not possible.
The incident occurred during a rampage
at the Freedom Plaza as part of a demonstration,
so it's the same location again.
Freedom Plaza.
The exact same location as the assault,
then she turns up there right before the explosion,
surely not a coinky dink.
As you know, Miss Watergate's still running around freely.
We should find out why.
We should also gather more background information.
I want to know who we're really dealing with.
No, don't be sorry for being late, silly goers.
You're not late at all.
Who is an artist by profession.
Okay, so we've got a job.
Related document found.
Oh yes, one who does street art
by blowing memorials to pieces by any chance.
Okay, so she did.
Great, you've found another document.
Before we go on, let's clarify your job.
Again, we're just in the tutorial section,
so don't be surprised there's a few pop-ups, okay?
Great, you've found another document.
Before we go on, let's clarify your job
and how it affects mine, shall we?
You have extracted all the info I already knew about her.
Starting now, I'm going into it blind.
The Orwell ethical codex dictates
that investigators like yourself
are the only ones allowed to access documents
of targeted persons.
Advisors like me only get to see the data
provided by the investigators.
We will then draw conclusions and request action.
Your primary job is to provide information
you deem important, never give away
incorrect or misleading data.
You may hit disable on a data chunk
you do not want to pass on to Orwell.
However, some data chunks might be necessary
to progress on a case.
Curious.
So, we have the option to ignore
something we don't like.
So that's the exact same picture.
Due to the chaotic nature,
police have not yet been able to
connect the crime by the artist,
has denied the accusation completely
and has asked their fans to show their support.
A trial has now been scheduled for mid-August.
Ooh, fancy.
Cassandra's portfolio.
Oh, I've got a new four-wall brochure.
Shoving new four-wall on her.
She's very smiley.
Oh, just for play.
Wait, you know what?
Oh no, we've got multiple if we wanted this one.
The accusatory.
Hmm, something's not going on here.
There's no such thing as a coincidence.
It's been a hot minute since the last
was this game.
I wonder if you can frame people.
Hi, I'm Cassandra.
A colorful inhabitant of Wonderland
right behind the rainbow.
Bet you are.
Glad you found me.
Finally found the courage to quit my dull
and focus on art career.
So she's an artist.
My U-Tail account.
Well, that's her job,
so I guess she can be an artist.
Previously, Claire job.
Yeah, that's fine.
Hmm, interesting.
Find out what job that was.
And then my account name is this.
Wonderlandster.
She reminds me of Nikki from Honeycap.
No, Nikki, but the bad end.
Good, you found a chat handle.
That will allow us to overhear any conversations
on that account.
How far fetched is this?
Surely this doesn't occur in real life,
and this is all fantasy based.
Anyway, hydration check, briefly.
The listener
has now been unlocked.
New conversations will appear
whenever they are started.
So we're going to listen in
on a conversation.
Oh, she's not online.
Well, I guess, no.
What's she got?
She's got pudders.
My beloved furball.
Kikiko.
Yep, the beaut is me.
I was never sure about the title,
Businessman's Forgotten Daughter.
Daughter of an in-entrepreneur.
Very...
Oh, listener.
Who's she talking to?
Hey, you.
Hey, Jossie.
Dot, dot, dot.
Oh, he's typing, sorry.
I can't seem to find my credit card.
I assume you took it right.
You got me, Sherlock.
Put the cat in the database.
Oh, is this her man?
I'm in the middle of buying all the Boston
with that platinum card.
I lifted.
Stolen a credit card from an unknown person.
I think that's her boo.
I don't... I don't think we...
We say that.
We're lucky for you.
I don't mind you going on a splurge
as long as you pick up some wine for dinner.
Yeah, they're mine.
Wine, what does Yosef Langley,
my fearless attorney,
and all-round badass have...
create new profiles?
Sure, that's on him.
Okay.
You now have a profile and a related person.
It could be access for you as a profiler.
Date chunks will only appear for target persons.
Okay, okay, that's fine, that's fine, that's fine though.
Let's get back into her.
Guess I better pick up tons of wine.
You'll have to get this client of yours
pretty buzzed to handle all that business.
One bottle should be fine, she's a lightweight.
Okay, I guess I shouldn't pick up some of those
party pills from Big Pharma.
Aki, my parent.
Daughter of...
Ooh!
Wait.
If you have Big Pharma parents,
what the fuck is...
Watergate Pharma, that does ring a bell.
Ooh!
Yeah, maybe.
Gotta go now, text you later.
Exo, exo!
She's dating...
A date from my darling.
She's in a relationship, okay.
Well, it was supposed to be...
Okay, there we go, we've scraped this website,
so we're gonna go back.
Procedure...
Closing raises...
Manipulation speculation.
Oh, that's her boo.
Orwell informs me you just encountered
conflicting data chunks.
Whenever the content of two data chunks
are odds with one another,
they will be shown as a conflict.
When you extract one of the data chunks,
containing a conflict,
the others will become invalid immediately.
I'd highly recommend that you clarify
in the context before you proceed.
Though this is your decision,
once information's been parsed,
there is no way to reverse the choice.
Okay.
Are we ready?
Oh, let's not fuck up.
Am I in the way?
I need to be smaller.
I don't want to be too small.
I don't know.
I don't know if I made myself smaller or made it worse.
Okay.
The case that is almost the center media attention
last month's come to an end.
Cassandra was acquitted for allegedly assault
with the case being closed due to lack of evidence.
However, the case might be reopened
with new evidence being discovered.
The suspect's lawyer,
at no point has there been any valid evidence
that my client was guilty.
No point at all.
Meanwhile, the relatives of the victim
expressed their disappointment on hearing
the result of the lawsuit.
They openly voiced concerns that
the wealthy family of the accused
might have influenced her favor.
The victim, a father of two...
Well, actually, I'm inclined to believe
there was lack of evidence because she was
beaten and she didn't resist the rest.
So, I'm actually going to submit this one.
But she was green.
And she didn't resist.
If you resist, then, yeah.
This is what I figure.
A pity that the CCTV did not actually help.
Maybe it will today.
So, how do I...
add her re-boyfriend?
You.
Doesn't let me add his face?
No?
Okay.
I don't undo that.
Hold on.
Right, back to her, back to her.
You don't have to resist
in your above-law correlation causation.
Indeed.
Why would someone...
Why would someone, by their full name,
one month member...
What?
What are you saying?
Time to become big brother.
Steady on, penthouse.
Amy's back, don't worry.
Right.
What is this?
Watergate pharmaceuticals.
Let's just have a little...
Ooh, lots of...
Oh, that's what you use to regain your...
See if your brain can put together
what the joke I'm forming.
Okay, let's check you out.
The company.
Ooh, is it her dad?
No?
That was before she got...
No, no, she got blue hair to symbolize.
She's radicalized.
Get wrecked.
That's hilarious.
So, she was...
Is that actually the same person?
She got fucking radicalized
and now she's blue.
Okay.
Well, she was the junior.
She's giving it up.
Right, her mom and dad.
Her mom and dad.
Okay, I see.
Now, keeping it a family affair.
So...
Update.
Junior...
No, she left it.
Documents that you already have reviewed
maybe update from time to time as events unfold.
The reader will notify you when that happens.
The National Beholder just published
a new article.
You may want to take a look
and see if there's any new information available.
Curious.
Is there anything else on the jobs?
Can I get hired?
Not...
Not, you know, feeling it?
Okay, fine.
Fine, fine.
So yeah, this is basically a click simulator,
but yeah.
Crane breaks continue to drop.
The bomb.
Wait, am I supposed to invest together?
The safety bill.
Go on then.
What's the safety bill?
I wanna know.
Crimes pair.
The safety bill is passed.
The party is elected to government.
Ooh.
Nineteen.
Eight.
So you mean to tell me that this woman
quit her QC100K job
to pursue art?
Honestly.
The...
Parge is peacekeeping.
Oh, the parge is the baddies.
Goodness me.
Talk about readings in your ear.
Wait, the headline says it's got an update,
but we are on this one.
It might be introled.
There's a red symbol.
I did get updated.
Hmm.
I'm missing something.
What?
It says there's something here.
It must be to do with the safety bill, no?
There's a bit of information
we're supposed to be extracting here,
and I can't find it.
Come on, game high.
Light it for me so I thought
to use my brain.
Due to recent stabilization,
we've been able to reduce
the number of station guards.
Okay.
Participate.
Become a party.
What?
Safety bill, just temporary, so.
Whoa, we've got the leaders.
Look at all those people and stuff.
Parge is peacekeeping.
Okay, we get it.
We get it, good, good.
I don't see any information position.
The five pillars of the great nation.
Safety and security.
Economy and commerce.
Values and tradition.
Migration and foreign affairs.
Education and health.
The five pillars.
Okay, okay, we get it.
Right.
What does that blue mean at company?
What does the blue mean,
that this information, can I not?
Well, she is an artist.
I guess that way everything stays in the family.
Being an artist and a junior seems a bit odd.
She also mentioned she'd quit a dull job.
Yeah, okay, well that's why I didn't put that down
because she quit it.
Okay.
Okay, I'm starting to get it.
I'm starting to get it.
Right, jobs.
What's going on here?
We are urgently looking for a replacement.
Okay.
You gotta go back to work, Rip.
Thank you for hanging though.
Please don't worry, this is a bit of a,
this is rather low energy.
We're gonna have a lot more fun streams next week,
I promise.
Or maybe I was wrong and nothing stays in the family.
Yup, this is probably what she meant by quitting her job.
Good.
Ooh, currently I'm thinking that our Miss Watergate
underwent quite a radical change, don't you agree?
Let's find out what happened
in between these two lives of hers.
What may have caused this shift?
Let's find out.
Because that timelines, what's timelines?
Oh, it's like Facebook.
Oh my God.
1992, she's old.
Do you remember in September?
I love the soft spoken art.
It's not the soft, me is just exhausted.
Look at all those, look at all those Eggman's profile.
She has an interest in art music and activism.
Well, there you go.
It's not that old.
1992, hag, that's weird.
Art music and activism, what a line up.
She only just called me old.
I don't mean that you're older.
I like it.
What do you mean someone so young and tiny
has so much control over you?
I mean, they mess up over a little bit.
Sorry, 1992, bro, is what you're old.
Yes, I'm old.
Bones are decaying.
They're becoming like powder.
Woohoo, first day freed and far away from the shackles.
So she didn't like her jab.
Despite, oh, despite puppets,
the spies you have finally managed to destroy.
So there's nothing left to do.
You can get there.
My person wishes for you deep as the best.
Opposes the government.
What's the matter?
That doesn't sound like you haven't hung out for ages.
Mary, shut your frickin' mouth, okay?
I'm not in the mood for your stupid act.
I told you again and again.
I can't deal with this right now.
You know what?
I'm really sorry that I still care about my best friend.
No matter how often she decides to give me the cold shoulder.
Because she's in a relationship.
Okay, we can confirm that.
You're randomly with the lawyer who might be noteworthy.
Is this the beholder?
Yeah, no, we knew it was him.
Hold on, go back to the timeline, please.
Right, you opposed the government.
No, no, no, can't have that.
Being against the government is very sus.
Well, well, Miss Watergate, we aren't too fond of you either.
Conflicting data.
I don't know what the conflict is, though.
At least you are redeemed.
I want to blow off some steam together late night shopping.
Not today, I have a date this evening.
Ooh, who's the lucky one?
Case closed, congrats.
I never had any.
Wait, Mary just seems really nice.
Oh my God, isn't that the singer of the gorillas?
Failed goods.
Camels looking down on the camel's back.
Hydration check.
You know who I mean, though.
I forgot his name.
Okay, what's looking...
Oh, here we go.
Cassandra Shobin of the world is singing now.
The concert is amazing, amazing.
I just had to give my hair a little makeover,
so without further ado, how do you like it?
Okay, so she changed her hair for a concert.
Cassie's gone punk.
Did Momay and Daddy agree with that?
Eggs, D.
Looks nice.
What new you?
You also need a new name.
What about this?
That's the spirit girl now.
I'd like to invite you to our little activist group
if you want to join us.
It would be nice to have you in the protest.
Oh my God.
I can't believe that the gorillas are against the government.
An activist group.
Is there anything more specific?
So hence what Cassandra Shobin known to the world is
Cassarthus.
It's not going to actually update her name.
Is this like a code name?
You guys get given code names?
An alias.
Okay, okay, okay.
An alias name.
You know people on the web.
So many names, so many identities.
It's always good to recover or record any alias.
Then we can match data chunks.
Okay.
Oh, there's a conversation.
Did I miss a conversation?
Oops, I did.
Oh no, here we go.
Recording starts.
Let's go.
Hey, did you hear about the
La Bomba?
Yeah, don't remind me.
You know I have history with that place.
So she's saying she wasn't there.
The plot thickens.
She's going by girls.
Already messing with me.
Enough that I have to catch a bus from there every day.
Catches a bus every day.
Okay, so we have evidence of her being at the location
due to that bus comment.
Meaning her presence there before the Bomba
could be a coincidence after all.
I'll reserve my thoughts and tell more evidence.
I'm so
co-member of thought,
member of a group of people
who have thought,
member of a group called thought.
If you would not have gone to the protest,
you never would have been wrongfully,
we'll keep that information wherever that is.
You are not a,
whoa, an activist group called thought,
interesting, maybe this is what,
the thought police, but the other way.
We should find something that shows
our current attitude to see if we're following
the right person.
Yeah, I would not have been called
an activist in all the papers.
You are not one, okay?
Aren't I?
You sure?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Ka-ching!
What?
Is that supposed to be my credit card
and the cash register?
Something like that, I guess.
I hope you, like, a
shatoo-monger.
And me just cringed, I'm sorry.
Great.
So you've decided to bankrupt me.
I'm your boyfriend, Yosef.
Uh, okay.
Here's the thing,
I've got an important appointment tonight.
It's surprisingly out on my schedule
and I can't postpone it.
Postpone it!
You've gotta be kidding me!
I want that thing!
I'm very sorry, darling.
We'll have to see each other tomorrow, Cookie.
You always have an appointment
exclamation mark one.
Appointment here, appointment there,
appointment fucking everywhere!
How can you constantly do this to me?
Darling, please just calm down.
Have you taken your drugs?
Oh my god.
Suspect is, is on, on drugs.
Wait, can you look that up for me?
Yeah, yeah, in a minute.
Fine.
If you don't show up at the appointment,
I risk losing a very important appointment.
Is he cheating on her?
You know, I feel like if you're a lawyer,
you have to make time for,
if a client comes first and through your doors,
you have to deal with it there and then.
No, no, I totally understand.
Don't you risk losing that very important client.
Don't be like that.
Come on, you know the, the de-fire.
The de-fire!
I get it.
I guess I'm just not an important client anymore.
Oh, come on, Kathy.
Going home now in case I'm getting up
on that priority list.
Please.
And then the session,
this one goes right.
Let's go figure out the product
that began with an M,
anti-depressant.
Oh no, she's so volatile
on anti-depressants.
Yeah, so I think we're going to be fine.
Oh, I clicked off that.
Looking at what you've experienced so far,
we're dealing with a potentially dangerous personality.
I will indicate that to law enforcement.
What?
What are you doing?
What anti-depressants?
Right.
I don't know what the conflicting thing is
with this Mary.
Having an amazing tour with Mary,
my best friend.
Right.
So she says best friend
and this is her with brown hair
at the best friend stage.
Just discovered this new band
The Targets, Man in the Rock.
Who's coming?
Punk's not my style.
Sorry, can't we just go see cherry cheeks sometime?
Well, you can see my cherry cheeks
any day we film.
They are just not some punks.
Their lead singers are real cutie
and they've got a...
Plus they've got a message.
Why not?
No, sorry, it's not for me.
And then what?
She starts changing.
Oh my God, what happened to you?
Oh, she's not replying to Mary at all here.
Congrats, I never had any doubts.
Oh, but she's not replying to Mary here.
She's only replying to Juliet and
Guerrilla Man.
Oh, they did fall out.
They have a broken friendship
because Cassandra's been a weirdo.
Guerrilla Man.
Yeah, broken house ad.
Yeah, and she got radicalized
and doesn't want to talk to her pal anymore.
Right, the thoughts.
The thoughts are free.
If liberty means anything at all,
it means the right to tell people
what they do not want to hear.
George Orwell.
It's thickened.
Oh my God.
Step one, secure the case.
Okay.
This is forbidden.
Oh no, is everything broken?
Let's do that.
Oh, there's her alias name.
Oh, she's already linked to all her stuff.
We know about you.
Step eight, Rizloth.
For you, Mason.
Not for me.
Need to get some work done today.
I'll have to catch the rest of the blood.
Okay, thank you for hanging.
Please don't worry, this is very, very low energy game.
So this is just chilling in the background stuff.
So don't worry.
We're even at Freedom Plaza.
Is that just me?
Or is that ironic?
You probably all know me.
It's either that blue-haired punk bi-youch.
Oh my God.
These are only some of the names
that we called during the criminal investigation.
That was because in the middle of the chaos,
someone believed to have seen me hurt an officer.
It never even occurred to anybody that it wasn't me.
We were there because we wanted a peaceful protest.
We have always been against violence.
Hmm.
And what's the conflicting data?
One would assume that in the age where
all the camps are everywhere,
I don't even find the conflicting piece.
By goldfells.
Where's the conflicting piece of information?
Alright, someone called Guest.
Hey, interesting name by the way.
Just stumbled upon your new blog and some truth here.
The web was born in the sense of ultimate freedom
to be who you want to be and express yourself.
Now that the government has threatened this
with real name policies and stuff,
saves your IP, so you can look up who you are.
Wasn't there...
Right, okay, this is Tinfoil Talk.
This is me, Tinfoil Talk.
I'm sure I saw a post that was like,
oh, sweet man-made thing beyond my comprehension.
And it was like, your PC can clock your room details
and the inside schematics of your house.
And I'm like, 99% sure that got proved
because it has like, something with it that can do that.
But I don't know if that's Tinfoil or if that's real real
and I fell for like a coffee past or something.
Oh, sweet man-made horrors beyond my comprehension.
Yay!
The best part of this game is when you start getting
how bad all the things are and you're doing the spine.
It can be done now, yeah, they use your router, yeah.
Yeah, hardware, back doors, and tracking every device.
Rep.
Okay, I thought I was making it up, but I guess it's real.
Hello, admin.
I'd like to say, could you be one...
To get a service on search engine, other...
Oh, is this just a fucking random mail?
What do you say?
Well, if you don't have one before,
you've just gained yourself your first follower.
Okay, let's go on his profile.
Hmm, it's got five articles.
Okay, and I'm guessing all the archive ones are inaccessible.
So, this has got conflicting.
There's a conflicting with show the conflict.
No, I don't know where it is.
No, it's not showing me where it is.
Oh, no, I'm gonna have to find it like a good girl.
Finally, someone who has the...
Oh, you've kind of fucked up with that one.
I have to admit.
You can't say you're about peace,
but then go on Facebook and be like,
XD.
Finally, someone who has the grit and explosives
to show how futile surveillance is.
C's assault justified for showing the futility of the surveillance.
Ooh.
Really cat?
You're laughing at people being killed.
Are you out of your mind?
Yeah, I'm sorry, but, bro, that's very tasteless.
I suspected as much.
Seems like we're looking at the right person.
I don't think it was her that did it,
but she's a sympathizer.
All right.
What we've found out so far is a good and interesting,
but I think we should be searching for something a little more concrete.
We have to dig deeper.
Okay.
Listening into a conversation.
Absolutely.
Juliet.
Hello.
Hi, Jules.
Is this so much fellow?
Cass, I just want to know.
Wanted to know.
You're post on timelines about the assault.
You really shouldn't write stuff like that.
Really, Jules, you're not going to preach to me about this stupid post, are you?
No.
I just wanted to know what's wrong, Cass.
It's nothing just between the two of us.
I just had to let off steam, you know?
It's because of what happened, isn't it?
Yeah, and lots and lots of other stuff, too.
The bombing stirred up all this crap again.
You know, what I did.
What did you do?
What happened there wasn't your fault.
Hey, Miss Tinfoil, what's the game about?
Tinfoil?
You'll never guess.
Cass, you hurt that officer to save me and you succeeded.
You mustn't forget about that.
How can it not have been my fault?
Juliet, I smashed a freaking skull of a father because I lost it.
Wait, what?
Admit guilt towards for having injured the officer.
To protect them.
Well, it was a protection job, so I'll let you.
I'll let you injure the officer to protect.
What? Where did that come from?
This is perfect. We can arrest her and open the investigation again.
However, we probably won't be able to hold her for long if that really happened in defense.
Very good work.
The intervention team is already on its way.
We'll need to wait for confirmation.
If Miss Water, in Miss Water Gates case, it was not a problem to get her dressed.
With the help of local police due to her former record.
Oh, Sheevie's getting a clip of her burp, by the way.
I just let you guys should know that.
And Amy sent me clips of her feet, so don't be shocked when you see shots like that.
I feel like a butthole and worse kind of butthole.
I might be free, but not right.
I'm not innocent.
Okay, nobody's innocent.
You'll have to let go.
Okay, we're learning.
Oh, wait, she's going back onto her.
It was a bit late in finding that info.
Five minutes later, Miss Timfoyle, or oh, she.
FBI, open up.
I thought about what you said.
Maybe you're right. I should take the post down.
Oh, we've already reported it.
You're a bit too late.
It would be better.
Believe me.
Are you getting taken down in real time?
FBI, open up.
By the way, how is your boyfriend?
You're still together.
You haven't been talking about him that much lately.
Well, not as much as before.
Oh my God, we're about to literally get it live streamed to us.
Hello?
Are you still there?
Too late, strong and co-locked you.
I'll inquire if all went well with arresting Miss Wargate.
You did a good job in any case.
Although we have no proof she's involved in the bomba.
We might be able to question her.
Despite acting in defense of Australia,
she seems to be quite unstable and unstable.
She's on anti-depressants.
She's just, you know,
seeing the world for what it is.
Okay, I just received information she's in custody.
Good work.
This thought group though, whether they, oh God.
No, no, no, take a look at the news.
They struck again.
That's horrible.
Two dead after second explosion.
Two dead, similar approach.
Same letter found.
So these are, letter?
I don't remember reading a letter.
And if that wasn't enough already,
Miss Wargate was in custody.
So that's her at the picture,
this complicates matters massively.
So much for our simple test case.
I need to speak to my superiors,
see how they are to proceed
given these extenuating circumstances.
You did good today.
You can log off and get some rest by clicking the button
on the top right of the desk.
Try and get some sleep.
I'm trying.
I have a feeling the next few days are going to be bad.
Let's see what this is though.
Explosion self at a university in Bondton,
at least two passed away, three injured.
Once again, a letter has been received
just before the crime.
Second bomb has hit freedom of square.
Even the game knows I need sleep through.
Are you sure you want to finish the work for today?
Oh, I'm pressed.
Oh.
What's been undone?
There was like one in here.
What?
A colorful...
No.
That's not going to disable it.
Okay.
Okay, so that's everything.
There was like one thing I omitted.
She celebrates people's death.
So yeah, I've done that a lot.
Even for me.
I have to be back there.
Bye bye.
That was the tutorial section done.
We've already done one out of five.
Okay.
Oh, I haven't got an achievement.
Complete episode one.
That's a lot.
I just want to say thank you to everyone
who's clipping the girls at any point.
It really helps them find clips faster
so we can shove them to the editing team.
That was the tutorial.
Yes.
I'm like 99% sure that was the tutorial.
I played this game out quite a few years back now.
I don't remember it that well.
She's been criminally charged in the past
with injuring an officer.
She's an artist.
Former criminal case.
But got dropped.
A second assault.
Activist group thought.
So we're going to have to look into that.
Okay, bedtime.
Good night guys.
See you tomorrow.
I'm so sleepy.
I just want to sleep on your chest.
I want to be like a cat and need into your chest.
Like me.
Okay, welcome back.
Hope you don't mind if we get started right away.
We have tons of work ahead of us.
I met with my superiors and they wished
to continue with the test case.
They believe in the capability of Orwell
to handle this.
Oh, Andrew of course.
Yes, me who's behind Orwell.
Okay, let's go to bed.
Yeah.
Gentle.
Okay, my superiors agreement.
Based on the information you have already extracted
the activist group known as Thought
is worth investigating.
It seems that this goldfills
is an important member of Thought.
So we now have clearance
to consider them a target person.
Are you going to part two?
Heck yeah.
I'm one like a mmm.
When it's good.
Sleep on our laps if you need rest, honestly.
I got a really cute fanart yesterday on Twitter.
I replied to it if you didn't see it.
And it was like all these reeflings in bed with me.
One of them was a furry.
They had an echo ears.
One looked like it had a wee mustache
when it was climbing on the bed.
Another reefling.
I think it was massage on my shoulders.
And like there's like three reeflings
bunched up on the other side of me.
It was really cute.
I liked it.
There's Kawainee.
I only remember like episode four.
It was probably my favorite.
Okay, now that goldfills is a target person
there may be a new data chunk
available in documents you have already
accessed.
Don't forget to go back and recheck your sources.
Okay.
Whoa, we are getting
a lot of...
Okay, so that's parents.
Yosef.
Yulia.
Yeah.
Okay, we've got a little bit of an up the entry one.
Our thoughts still free.
Okay, we've got a pic.
Nope.
Let's push up on you.
Let's add your picture, bruv.
Just needed one reading.
You go the F to sleep.
I might make that.
I think it's quite humorous.
Okay, I propose to consider the question
are our thoughts still free?
Well, this might seem to be a surprising question.
In our current world of ever growing digital surveillance
freedom of thought is no longer self-evident.
Dear reader, there is a German folk song
called the thoughts are free.
It goes like this.
Thoughts are free.
Who can guess them?
They fly like the nocturnal shadows.
No man can know them.
No hunter can shoot them with the powder and lead.
Thoughts are free.
I am not reading this properly.
I think what I want and what delights me
still always...
Ah, I don't know these words.
Okay, when I was a young lad,
long before I immigrated to the nation in 1993
memes are free, exactly.
That's the best.
I cannot read chunks like this.
It's going to mess with me.
An immigrant.
Oh no, the racism starts quick.
This is why I created this blog.
Okay, so he's a creator of thoughts,
which is fine.
Get to know the thoughts in activist group
with the same name as this blog.
If God fails as the one who created the blog,
perhaps he founded or even the leader of the activist group.
Hiya.
Oh, they're just talking.
Okay, that's the same comments as before though.
Mentions focused on thoughts are free.
I mean, this is such a small nuance.
Okay, headlines.
What's today?
Connection between the bomba to the gallows.
Write that down, write that down.
Random German in the chat that I can't translate.
Heavy rainstorms expected.
That's very important.
Yes, yes.
Timeline and Rossin announced cooperation.
Who are they?
The Davenport siblings, owners of the biggest social network.
Oh no.
Everyone's surveilled and said 10 times harder.
Let's see what the bomba is going on.
Any highlighting notes?
No.
What about this?
That is all your personal data.
Just get on like that.
We are literally singing the song you saw a minute ago.
Oh, where he is?
I'm so sorry.
I don't recognize that.
Cassandra update.
What's going on with you?
Oh, she is redacted.
She's in trouble.
Okay, there's something here on the website.
I think.
Is there something on the website?
I have a little red mark.
Do I really need to...
Okay, fine.
Our report thoughts are free.
Okay, right.
Just if it's harmless, report it.
The letter.
We are right, it seems.
That's what the letter says.
The thoughts are free?
That's terrible.
If that's true.
Who's listening?
Hey, you.
Hi.
I'm sorry about last night.
I really should have come over.
Well, you didn't.
So what are you going to say to that?
What's the calling card?
Where did we get it?
Wait a minute.
The government doesn't want you to know this,
but thoughts are free.
You can just take them.
Yank.
It's just that this client is massively influential
and could have break a whole lot of exposure.
I've been trying to get a meeting for months
and it went rather well.
So here's hoping.
God, I'm such a stupid old man
who just talks about his job too much.
I'm sorry.
It's just a big part of my life.
Hello?
Are you still upset?
Oh, he doesn't know that she's in jail.
She's got the jail.
Can you answer me if you don't?
I'll start to worry.
You know what I'm like?
She's in jail.
You just don't know.
Okay.
I thirdly believed we are able to capture minds
if only we could garner attention to the group.
After one and a half years recruiting two of my students
and arranging three demonstrations.
So he's the one that's kind of mastermind in it a bit.
Three demonstrations.
More interesting might be the two students
that were involved.
Okay.
Frankly and sadly, the answer to the latter is a resounding no,
which was the question was are we true to the initial goal?
We let ourselves be consumed by anger and hatred
towards those who did wrong.
Reacts with hatred and anger about troubled past of thought,
hinted at troubled past.
Thoughts are free, but that does not mean that we can attack
or do whatever they wish instead of blaming others.
I see now my high aims might well be the cause
for all of the events of the past months.
More than anyone else have thought, I feel responsible.
Hmm.
Feels responsible.
Reacts with hatred and anger.
I think feels responsible.
Because look, as a consequence, I'll halt my activities.
So he feels responsible.
Okay.
I will halt my activities.
Oops, sorry.
A troubled past, we will have to get to the bottom of this.
But he's going to stop his activities.
Oh man, my duck army crew is a violent group.
Write that down.
Whatever active engagement means still an interesting fact.
He is a lecturer at a university.
Yes.
Oh, and we've got a really good thing.
What now?
Still again?
The same still again where the bomb popped its clogs?
You know what I think about coincidence is I ain't going to repeat it.
So far the evidence suggests that Goldfels was a prominent lecturer
and some of his students became involved in thought.
Did he like recruit them for the cause?
We need to identify those students.
See who else is involved in that group.
Concerned number one.
Please reconsider.
Guy, her, there was only a call.
They had it coming.
It was messy, I know.
You made the news.
Beryl, thank you for becoming a member for a month.
A little celebration anniversary.
It works on you.
You didn't put a wee thing.
You could have put a message.
I can read it.
You forgot to put a message.
It's okay.
Okay.
I'll just make up a message.
Strongly love.
Briefing love.
Okay, I made it for you.
Continue to main page.
What's going on here?
Yesterday there was a microwave incident with popcorn in a blue.
It wrapped itself up in tin foil and blew itself up.
Are you squidding me right now?
Nugget.
Nugget said a message.
Thank you for becoming a member for a month.
How do you say it?
Did I be like, oh, thank you for the repeated membership?
Or continued membership?
Yeah.
Thank you for the continued membership.
Why, yes, of course.
Are you squidding me right now?
It's already been a month.
That's pretty crazy.
Honestly, all things considered.
How did we get here?
Oh, my God.
Thanks for the sub.
Thanks for the second month.
Oh, yeah, it's technically the thing.
It's technically the second.
No, one full month because it starts on zero.
So this is the first full month.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Oh, you've all got blue seashells now.
Sally sells seashells by the seashore.
He's retired.
Oops.
Who's this?
Oh, it's him.
Got another picture of him.
We are in the second month.
Blue seashell team.
Being a luminary in his profession.
Oh, Abraham is his name.
Gladly accepted that.
Oh, Abraham is well done.
Professor in the field of media ethics.
He had sadly retired.
I've got to wait two more days.
Can you last two more days?
Yeah, I think you can.
Be good and wait.
Did you notice the bomber seems to be closely connected to thought?
There could be pattern.
Thought had held three demonstrations.
Actually, what I've got a bone effect.
Hold on.
I've got a bone effect with a certain marshmallow.
I have a bone effect with a certain marshmallow.
I'm going to read it out.
It was so bad.
I'm reading it out.
And you know exactly who you are.
Who fucking sent this.
Hold on.
Let me find it.
Where is it?
It was a recent one.
That's right.
You're in trouble, Riflin.
You're in trouble.
And you know exactly who you are.
I'm going to read this.
Because Riflin, you had nothing but the audacity.
Imagine I'm railing you in your bedroom
and your dad comes home early and sees me pounding you
and slapping your cheeks while you scream harder.
With that end, okay?
What if he sees the creation of her child, his grandchild?
How embarrassing.
I'd be so ashamed, Lamal.
Riflin, who the fuck sent that?
Who sent that with their whole chest?
Who formulated those letters?
Which one of you did that?
I know you're cackling behind the keyboard right now.
If I ever, if I ever spot you at a convention,
if I ever, your left ball is getting upped.
I don't remember sending that now.
Absolutely not.
Right.
Thought has held three demonstrations,
yet there has only been two bomba,
which might imply, well, it's definitely shot in the dark,
but we absolutely need to do everything we can
to prevent another attack.
Take a close look at the path of each member with thought.
Find out the locations of all demonstrations
that have held that might yield a hint.
Why only the left one?
Because I need to pick on one.
It was either left or right.
I'll pick on your left ball instead.
She pops your left ball.
You'll never have a daughter.
That's how it works, right?
No!
Thought it all works at all.
That's funny.
Okay.
Journalist at Der Reporter.
One of the most...
Oh, it's German.
Sorry.
Like Der.
You lose one chromosome that you can pass over.
Okay.
Formula G.
And was also chairman of Global Media...
Man, this guy has quite the portfolio on him.
Jeez.
Chairman of an ethical congress,
just to average one of the mill.
Steady on sims.
I think you've been a bit radicalized yourself, mate.
Wow, that's a whole lot of information about this fella.
Yet, only one other page could be indexed.
Very strange indeed.
I think the next course of action should be to look for other people of this group,
like the students he mentioned.
Thoughts are free.
Oh, okay.
This is another link.
A modern time declaration of independence towards mass surveillance.
Cure it.
Your genes become joints.
Well, what do you say to that?
He literally wrote the book.
Well, yeah.
Okay, what's the headline?
Breaking news.
First suspect in connection.
Who?
Women arrested in connection.
Oh, okay.
They've broken the news, right?
What's going on?
Whoa, there's like a lot of new information on this page.
Home.
What's new on it?
Wait, did I not just...
There's nothing new on this.
I'm being trolled.
Oh, these are students.
Did I need to interact with them?
Because I said I needed to get students.
I bet he stopped leading the group and one of his radicals took over.
I am leaving that too.
Why can I not interact with them?
Maybe I interact with the later stage.
Attendee list.
Okay.
I don't know where you found that.
Summer?
Wait, where's his class?
I'm freaking to say I'm actually going to have to use my head.
Hold on.
Right.
What was his class again?
Media Ethics.
Okay.
Okay, take me to the list.
Winter.
Media.
And then what's his name again?
Big...
Big Gold Felt.
I would be terrible at this job.
I already forget the names.
Right.
I think you're already retired at this point, so you don't count.
Okay.
So then go Previous.
Then go Summer.
Then go Media.
And then look for Gold Fells.
Gold Fells.
Abraham.
Nothing's been highlighted.
Oh.
Juliet.
Ooh.
We're seeing that name before, haven't we?
Right.
She was a friend of Miss Wargate.
Now it appears that she's a student.
I think that's enough to warrant a report.
Give me a few minutes.
Alright, we have authorization to investigate her.
Oh.
Okay, we have a profile now.
O'Donnell Harrison.
What's that then, too?
Joseph Lang is Cassandra's boyfriend and on the
Illumini list.
Ooh, I didn't spot that.
Harrison O'Donnell.
Yes, we have seen that name as well.
I'll report this right away.
Yes, yes.
We have been authorized to consider Harrison.
Oh, that was the gorilla guy.
Now there's some more work for you.
Congrats.
Okay.
Harrison and Juliet, they must be students within
Thought.
Well done.
Okay.
Anyone else?
Nicholas Webb.
Wheeler.
William.
Right.
Oh, we've got their timelines.
Okay.
First profile picture.
Next.
Your job, which is a PR assistant at
Rosen Tech.
Your birthday is February,
1992.
God, we even have your location.
This is too easy, bro.
Okay.
Fair view.
We even got location.
Interest, guitar singing, board games.
It's not really necessary.
I mean, I guess I'll just take it because it's a
wee thing.
It's not really that interesting.
Ha, you can dance and I got the proof now.
Oh, is that really me?
I'm going to be careful around you apparently.
Great photo though.
You took it.
Nice try, Jules.
A magician never reveals her trick.
Anyway, thanks for a great time.
I must admit, it felt kind of good to go out for once.
Not that I plan on doing it again any time soon.
Well, every time I ask you out, you still go out that busy
and then you fall for freaking muffins.
Wait, did he just call the blue here when a muffin?
Sorry, Adam.
Maybe you need to spy on me somewhere.
Oh, okay.
That was rather random.
I've got to go walk the dog.
Okay.
Where's my collar?
Put on me.
Sorry, that was really cringe.
Even I made myself grimace there.
I was like, ooh, steady on.
I'm bored to death.
I'm making cupcakes.
That girl next door.
You know, I'm not so keen on going out late.
Plus, I don't dance.
Okay, no.
All right, all right.
You're going to be there tortured by my girlfriend.
No.
Oh, friend, engaged in torture.
Don't be silly.
The pet play allegations.
Wait.
Someone said all of us are in on that.
And I'm like, is Azura in on that?
I didn't think Azura had anything to do with pet play.
Ooh, I actually needed to ask you.
I was going to order a collar and a bowl,
but I don't know if I put wreathling on it,
like your name on it.
I put wreathling on that and then it's like
I'm property of wreathling.
Or do I need to put my name on it?
I don't know how it works.
Put wreathling on the bowl.
Okay.
Okay, so I put your name on it
because you own me.
Okay, got it, got it, got it, got it.
Happy birthday, honey.
So glad to have you back.
We are the Kerrytons.
Welcome to our website.
Ooh, look at all these people.
Oh, she's having a good time.
Sushi.
Oh, I'm hungry now.
Whoa.
Whoa, she got more of her thing there.
Yeah, because you're not dumb enough to do the opposite.
Azura would be the owner in anything.
Put ink jar on it.
Okay, I'll order my little doggy bowl
and my collar.
Her favorite color is red.
She likes playing a guitar
to kill a mockingbird.
I've still not read the other one yet.
Since the nestling of the family
showed up a little bit, the parents,
John and...
Okay, so we have father and mother.
Decided that they would end
the strictness of naming pattern her sister.
Juliet played guitar.
Yeah, we get it.
She decided to enter band career
once she was single again.
There's a conf...
And focus on her university studies.
So we have undeniable proof
that she was in the class of that guy.
We just need to find this conflicting date.
And we'll find this part of it.
I feel like you don't want us wearing tinfoil
considering your plot.
Red might be important
if the letter is written in a certain color.
What's she doing?
Nobody...
Nobody took notice.
Nobody cares, nobody.
What did Harry do this time?
Ooh, she's dating Harry.
Even though Cassandra and I
just got to know each other as a protest,
she stood up for me.
Okay, so we have...
We have proof that they also met as well.
This woman is a hero and not a terrorist.
Rick Denton?
How come you care so much about politics now?
This doesn't sound like the Juliet.
I know.
You wouldn't even accept
the Juliet being class representative.
How come you care so much about politics?
And go for it.
Sometimes people change their minds.
First Miss Watergate and now hers.
There's some sort of brainwashing going on.
I understand.
Strongly.
The high table.
That's not funny.
Ooh, this guy's a bit more smart
with his information.
Harrison, we've got a picture of him.
He says Media Punk, though.
Sure.
We'll put that as your occupation
for now.
Media Punk.
What does that even mean?
This is being deleted.
Deleted multiple posts.
Ooh.
Do we have something to hide,
Mr. O'Donnell?
Always hiding everything.
Ooh.
You got this couple rock the show
as it will rock the rest
of the goddamn nation.
Well, you've posted proof
that you were with the other girl.
Juliet is a, yeah.
Our two student members of Thought
are a couple, interesting.
Mike, why didn't you go and ask Juliet
out right away, huh?
No need for hiding anything.
I can provide a nose correction
just for you to make you look like a...
Just...
You want that?
No, then Ethel.
If you got it flunked,
oh, so he gave a compliment
and he's coming in region.
Easily jealous.
I mean, that's not really
gonna help find the bomba.
There we have the connection.
Connection.
Yeah.
Okay, I don't really think it's
necessary to put in, like,
the smaller details like that.
Harrison likes to target
the haunted house with the cash
instead of the clash.
The national beholder.
We hold the ThunderDome.
Okay, welcome.
Rosin Technologies.
What are you?
A Rosin is the family.
Oh, we've got a listen.
Sorry, we've got a listen.
Sorry.
Oh, she got access to her phone.
What happened yesterday?
You got yoinked.
Juliet, this is
Yosef on Cassandra's account.
Oh, my God, what?
Wait,
did I have a profile on Yosef?
I must have.
This is the correct account.
It's disabled.
Oh, right.
I can only do it on her.
Sorry, I didn't.
I didn't drop it.
Not too uncommon in a relationship.
Oh, sorry.
Hi.
Didn't know you had access to her.
Nice to talk to you too, Juliet.
Have you seen Cassandra since yesterday?
Heard from her.
I spoke to her last night via chat.
She seemed quite upset
about the whole plaza thing.
And something else
she wouldn't talk about,
then there was something at her door.
Someone at her door.
So she went to answer it
and never came back.
I assumed it was you.
We were supposed to meet for dinner
but I had an unexpected meeting.
She wasn't exactly happy
about the change of plans.
She quit the chat.
And that was it.
I haven't heard from her since.
In that case,
I think she's probably home
stewing away.
Well, I just tried that.
She gave me the keyster a flat
two months ago,
but no Cassie,
also her PC was still on.
Hmm, I guess.
Calling her didn't work.
No, I tried.
Damn, I hate myself right now.
Did you set your number to private?
Otherwise, she's probably
just avoiding you.
Private is my default
after all I am a lawyer.
No, Cassandra's not a lawyer.
Oh, the fuck,
ignore that.
Cassandra's not a lawyer.
Must be meticulous as possible.
We will get to the bottom of this.
When she's mad,
she usually goes to wonders
around the city.
She'll be back in no time.
Yeah, she does get
about fiery at times.
Fireball.
That doesn't really work
like wild card.
There's the refland
that's been put in wild card.
In my marshmallow.
And I'm like,
okay, that's actually,
wait a minute,
do you think this guy's
one on her account?
The lawyer's on her account.
Are you trolling me?
Are you messing me up on purpose?
Oh, I doubt that somehow.
Oh, sorry.
See, this is why I want to,
I feel like you know
are better than I do.
And I'm the boyfriend.
Oh, I doubt that.
I mean, you two were
at the plaza together.
And so I thought maybe
you'd know other places
that could be important to her.
I'm sorry, freedom plaza
was organized by thought.
Yeah, but Harrison
did all the planning.
What's the conflict?
I must know.
You must let me know
the conflict.
I must find the conflict.
Harrison did the planning,
apparently,
as our little gorilla's
listener wild card is.
Thank you.
Anyway, session closed.
Right.
So we need to find the conflict.
The Ten Commandments.
Okay.
I was like,
Serion, what's going on here?
Oh, we've got a phone number.
Oh, Julie.
Gate card.
Well, good work.
The listener will also track
incoming, outgoing telephone
calls of numbers you've added.
It's not really that farfetched,
is it?
Oh.
Did we get to hear voices?
Oh, no.
Welcome to Brusenthek.
This is the PR assistant, Juliet.
How can I be a servant?
Hello, this is Esther.
You sound so official at work.
Oh, hi, Mom.
What's up?
How's that going in?
The Harrison character's looking
sus as anything.
I have to agree.
I am going home for it lives
with her parents.
Okay.
So when we take her down,
we need to remember the parents
when actually I'm heading out
with some friends.
Now let's find her parents address.
She plans on going abroad.
Sure, you can make plans
go for it.
Now I'm back.
How's the case going?
Ah, Juliet is apparently broken up
with the guy that planned it.
Honey, please, you won't have much
freedom left if you're passed away.
Mom, I won't die.
How can you be so sure of that?
I could just as easily be hit by a car
on the way home.
Don't say that.
Just think this ridiculous grip
I've gotten you into nothing but trouble.
Alright.
Sheesh.
Thank you, honey.
Mom, I'm sorry.
But I really have to go.
I don't want to be fired by my boss,
Victor Rothen.
I have to go.
I'm sorry.
Love you.
Bye-bye.
Curious, curious.
Okay.
So we have a boss, which is fine.
We're allowed to have bosses.
Huh?
Wait, what the actual...
The moment you open the dock,
well, this is...
Code Injection was detected in Orwell.
We've had 47 attack warnings
and still counting what is on that site.
Okay, okay.
Let's get off it.
So we don't get hacked.
We got malware.
Band, we are track.
We are the track you are ashamed of
in your fine-tuned playlist.
Oh, okay, that's funny.
Okay, hold on.
We're getting somewhere with this guy.
He cannot run away from us.
His name is Hancock.
The cogs are turning in my head.
If I had enough sleep,
I already would have said something wildly inappropriate.
Oh, that's quite the ego we've got there, haven't we?
Here's a wee photo of ya.
Upload.
Yeah.
That one looks more complimentary.
Warmer members.
Juliet.
Wrong profile.
But that's okay,
because we have Juliet.
Mummy downloaded the popcorn.
They got me.
See, that's what happens if you don't have a pie hole.
Wait, that's just that picture flipped.
The other way.
No.
Right, okay.
Let's do the professional one.
Nah, okay.
No.
Dude, the flipped one.
Sorry.
I know it doesn't even matter,
but I didn't find it.
Right, gigs.
Where are they playing?
I want to see them.
The target's featuring tearing down his cancel.
He decided to quit.
A friend of mine claims he heard that he quit,
but no official statements be given out.
A whole hearted thumbs down.
Oh, boo, thumbs down, boo.
Fucking thumbs down.
Okay, I'm not going to report that,
because that was a claim.
The cell.
We'll definitely come to Freedom Plot.
I just have to get to know Juliet,
especially since she's the one organizing.
Well, so Cassandra claims that Juliet did it,
but I'm going to be honest,
Juliet isn't striking me.
We'll definitely come.
I have to go because Juliet is doing a show conflict.
And so I thought maybe no other places should be important to her.
I was organized by thought,
yeah, but Harrison did all the planning.
I want to say Harrison did it.
Yeah, because she doesn't have a clue where else she might be.
I'm going to say Harrison did it.
I might regret this, but I don't know.
From the two conflicts,
it kind of seems like she's just tagging along with him.
He planned the protest that went completely awry.
He doesn't sound like,
doesn't sound like a good plan into me.
I bet you were going to say Hancock up at my house.
No, I couldn't come up with the funny enough joke.
Or maybe it didn't go awry at all.
Maybe it went down exactly as he had in mind.
We'll have done it now.
That Freedom Plaza demonstration was one of thought's protest,
not in surprise.
One down, two more locations to go.
Oh, what have we got?
No, not another phone call.
Oh, they're talking to each other.
Ring ring, hello.
You've got a Donald.
Harrison, it's me.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, look who it is.
I know this moment is coming to you.
But you've caught me by surprise.
I've already got a handle on it.
Shh, Juliet.
Ever since we first made out on that night,
I knew it was...
Oh, no, he's a stalker.
Will you please spare me?
I didn't believe you, but it really is you.
Uh, okay.
Steligan again.
The university needs to play a major part.
And what do I owe the beautiful pleasure of your voice?
You miss me.
So this is why you did it, to make me call you back again?
The heck are you talking about?
Oh, don't play dumb, great administrator.
I'm talking about the thought page.
You're so generously volunteered to maintain.
Wait, give me a sec.
What the...
You're messing around with me, Jules.
Are you seriously trying to say this wasn't your doing?
Rather eff would I disgrace thought.
Maybe because the same reason you bailed out of thought all of a sudden.
Wait, why would you plan it and then bail?
Thought you didn't...
Oh, so...
Oh, is that so?
We need to keep observing.
Okay, hold on.
I can't read that fast.
Thought you didn't do...
Since Abe disappeared.
Disappeared causing thought to come inactive.
Where does that...
Who does that go?
On her?
Wrong, but wait, what?
Oh, on Abraham.
Sorry, on Abraham.
Okay, so Abe disappeared.
Perfect voice acting, I'm so sorry.
Abraham Goh feels disappeared causing the group to be out.
They're no longer active?
Well, seems like someone still is.
To bail on the two of us.
Former relationship ended...
Why is that changing?
Former relationship.
Wrong profile.
Sorry.
Okay, so I'll update for both of them.
Okay.
Trouble in paradise.
Maybe then because you disgraced...
Hit articles on the blog.
Oh...
Except for Cassandra's.
How's that?
Curious, need to add that.
So he hit them on purpose except...
First the timeline, now the blog.
You have a lot to hide.
Hmm.
Abraham archived the first ones because they didn't want us to know.
Hit first articles and thought from other members in the public.
None of us could ever actually, I merely did the same with the rest
because that would also be in Abe's interest and Cass
wanted to show her article around.
What a strange development.
Oh, that guy that archived.
This gets more confusing by the minute.
Why don't you, why do you hide something on a group blog
from its own members?
A hidden agenda?
Oh please, I know you deleted all of your rebellious posts
to secure your cosy job and writing
that ridiculous opinion column for the TNB.
Wait, he writes...
He writes for the very thing he swore to destroy?
Hey, I read this one quite...
It wasn't at all where it was this guy.
Probably the thing don't know it.
You know, it's funny you dare speak of disgraces
when Rossin is the government's personal beat
because you didn't know, almost makes you the same.
So you really didn't hack then?
I didn't have a freaking clue.
Can you revert the changes?
You bet.
I'll even hunt down that son of a...
Just revert it, okay?
I don't care who did it.
I just can't stand her memories being toyed around.
Okay, okay, I'll be done in a minute, man.
I never could say no to you.
Oh, he's like a little puppy dog.
I will break you like that.
Okay, right.
Wait, so why is this red?
Or is it just red because it's new?
Probably just because it's new.
What's the albums?
I had a punk friend that he is now a real corporal
working for a bank.
I cry every time, you know.
Will we listen to the music?
Why is it only in my left ear?
Advertisement for the poor.
All right, I predict all right.
Oh, well, we've got an email from him.
That was literally only in my left ear.
I'm like, oh, thank you for donating me.
Excellent.
We will now have access to any emails coming in and out.
Oh, what's going on?
I see you.
Knock, knock, Harrison seems I caught your pants down
on that little page of yours.
Confused, that's fine.
You don't know me, and I like to keep it that way.
But I know a lot about you, media punk.
If I knew...
Oh, so he got scared.
If you knew what I know about...
What?
If you knew what I know,
what you know about what this little group of yours did,
you would find it just as hard to ignore
that those bomba might be carrying your name tag,
get what I'm talking about right.
So the Righteous Hacker initiate
will expose all information I got on you.
Might interest the cops.
I've no love for the government, but I'll do what I must.
So give me one good reason not to do it.
He got blackmailed by an anonymous person.
From initiate.
Oh, great.
Now there is a hacker involved in all this
because the situation wasn't bad enough already.
I wonder what this is about.
Let's find out.
Order confirmation.
Shoot, Angela?
Your bank account.
Okay, give me them bank account numbers.
Those are mine.
Those are not yours.
I don't know if we need a friggin' Angela.
Harrison sent...
No one cares about an Angela.
I see you.
Hey, wise ass.
This is the most pathetic attempt I've seen in a long time.
You want a goddamn reason?
I'll give you.
You hacked my site.
My website.
Last I checked.
That's illegal.
Something about glasshouse and stones.
I don't get what you want to have found out.
Oh, my God.
Am I reading this?
I don't get what you want to have found out about me.
True.
Our protest didn't go as planned,
but since you claim to know so much about me,
you shouldn't know.
That was hardly what I wanted was all in my blog.
In the blog, I mean.
It was getting hard to read.
It's not going well.
Not worried about the bomba.
Only grabbing attention.
Bet you'll be found out, huh?
With your mad skills.
Hey, good boy.
I'll throw you a breadcrumbs so you don't...
Mine.
Your dick.
I'm the wrong person to leave my page alone,
roll it back, and then don't there touch it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Sorry.
Shy.
Well, back off.
Right, why are the gigs highlighted?
So he quit the band,
and it's not conflicting,
so I'll just put he quit the band.
Internet vigilante easy.
The national opinion.
It really is by him.
There's three conflicting data chunks.
Oh, God.
Who knows?
Maybe the next one will go in the middle.
Predicted assault at a national museum.
I mean, we'll put that down
if he's predicting stuff.
He's been to the last two.
Okay.
Yes, the article.
That was strange indeed.
And with the bomba.
Jeez, Louise.
Juliet's timeline.
What's going on with you, Juliet?
I even organized...
You organized the peaceful protest on campus.
Right.
So Juliet did the campus organization.
Apparently there's information.
A house.
We're getting somewhere with you, Juliet.
She's somewhere from here.
The audio is a bit loud.
Like in-game audio or me.
I assume in-game audio got her address.
We got her ass.
I assume there's like nothing.
These are all like in-game audio.
I put it down by two decibels.
I didn't know.
I assume the red means there's something hidden on it
that I'm supposed to be looking at.
Is there more?
Oh, there's a new picture of them.
You're loud as fuck.
Oh, shit.
I'm actually...
You guys just tolerating this the entire time?
No, you're fine.
Oh, okay.
Comments.
I love you.
You're so amazing.
My new favorite band.
Greatest band of the nation.
Except for the proclaimers.
And stuff you did.
That was really good.
Please make yourself louder.
Wait, are you trolling?
You're trolling.
Okay, so...
We'll rinse the website.
Okay, we've got a new one.
Welcome to FBTN-
Wait, we can just straight up go into his bank?
I mean, he's got health insurance?
And he's...
A guy his age planning on doing something dangerous.
And then he needs medicine.
Comments are literally us for real.
That comment...
Whoa, what are you...
Oh, you got...
That...
See, that's an incentive to...
Do stuff against your actual personal beliefs.
If you're getting that kind of money for doing an article.
There's no way that's how much money you get for an article.
Must be the payment for writing the column.
Yeah, there's no way.
Can we delete this?
Oh my god, delete it please.
Delete it before I get booted out of his bank, please.
Delete it, delete it.
Okay, the...
Hancock's writing on the wall.
Is this his blog?
What is?
What?
After years,
After years, my plan has taken shape.
It even has name thought.
Finally, counterpart to the radical regime of totalitarian surveillance.
And I'm glad to have a capable companion in this.
One who came up with the best idea for a demo, whatever.
I'm not gonna tell you this as far as...
I can only urge you to join us in our aim
to unleash this pitiful, pathetic wannabe democracy
of a country from its shackles.
From freedom is not free in a place
where every move is observed and analyzed.
Wait, so he made it?
Run around.
I already got a nice plan on.
As soon as I get myself a handful of like-minded people,
we're gonna occupy the university.
I bet we could scare those cardigan-wearing conformists
a great deal by showing our ugly faces.
Oh, how I'd love to see them running.
I already live in a trailer.
There we go.
Can play city skylings one day.
You can make a reefling city.
Oh, can I?
Oh, come on.
Can you please get any more stereotypical antisocial?
So what's the conflict?
Plan to occupy the university.
Planned a protest.
So he's, he, as soon as I get myself like,
we're gonna occupy.
But she said she planned it.
I think he's the mastermind behind it.
So we'll do occupy instead of protest.
It was an occupy he originally wanted to do.
Very well.
It is apparent, extreme, exactly as we suspected,
but we still have no idea about the third location.
You need to be diligent now.
Lives may be hanging in the balance.
In the worst case,
that we cannot determine the location on time.
Well, I might have to conduct an interrogation
with Miss Watergate.
I want to avoid it though, she's behaving
pretty defiantly, I've been told.
Looking at what you found so far,
I think I might have enough information
to put some pressure on her.
No, no, no, I'm not done reading the book yet.
Stop.
Knock, knock.
The thoughts are free once again.
We are not done yet, you and me.
But first, on, I must turn to another.
I can't even find the word to him.
Stupid, rejects government's proposition.
And then the confliction is...
No, so he doesn't actually support it.
He got a fat paycheck,
so whatever the other confliction is.
Outskirts.
Camping?
He lives in a camping ground.
Okay, we've got this location.
Nothing wrong with cardigans,
leave the cardigans alone.
That's one ugly place,
but I guess it's cheap.
Okay, so I'm gonna wait.
There are so many updates.
Okay, user, fricking...
What?
Archived, archived.
We can still archived.
The website's back.
Everything's archived.
Mm-mm.
Everything?
Okay, would you need that?
Entry 8.
Just here?
No, we've just got access to it again.
Okay, we've just got access to it again.
That's hot.
Seems like...
Ever family?
There's something lurking on ever family.
Whatever it is.
What is it that's lurking?
Okay, playing the guitar
proves that she was definitely in the band.
I'll allow it.
Favorite color, red?
Does this even have anything to do with anything?
I feel like I'm just clogging up the system.
Okay, I like jokes as much as the next person.
But our favorite color, do you really think that is...?
Okay, there is a bomb threat.
Could you please focus on that?
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Okay, I got a little distracted.
Okay, wall attacks.
The important thing is here.
Leave a message.
The alien.
I'm looking for people willing to join a thought.
I can live it up.
Oh.
Wait.
By pure coincidence,
I stumbled on it.
Frankly, you're thinking in your attitude
to get people thinking
is left an impression on me.
So the professor
messaged him.
The professor didn't recruit them.
Thank you for joining.
I feel a little confused now.
Is this thought a blog,
an activist group,
or a debate club,
or all three?
They're just really good at master debating.
Okay.
This is curious.
I can't even find the words.
Okay.
We need to find that third debate club invitation.
There is no way they put old memes in this.
Are you joking?
Favorite color, red.
Red.
Red wire.
Bomba.
Color red wire.
Exactly.
They put an old meme.
Ain't nobody got time for that.
Why is that donkey?
Little donkey.
Carry me.
On the dust.
So Nina, you will be very recruited.
Nina.
Nina, Nina, Nina.
I don't know who Nina is.
So there's another member
we haven't even heard of.
I would request clearance to make our target.
We got the green light.
They instantly give the green light.
At concerned one, Nina.
Oh, that was that comment on the blog.
What a strange alias name.
Ain't nobody got time for that.
If someone's comment,
no comment.
No, there was a comment.
There it is, concerned.
No, we will carry into the streets of the nation,
be transformed in the re-implanted back of their minds
an invi-is-able idea that we shall always be free.
Declare thought to be a revolutionary act of this group.
Yes, I'm getting that vibe too.
Donkey Girl for Gen 2.
You guys are getting absolutely annihilated
next week when we actually draw the concert.
So an activist group after all
and now we know who had the primary say in it.
Any plans to restrict first?
Oh!
So what about holding a proclamation
on a government building then?
Sounds like a worthy first demo.
A proclamation?
We should go first storm in the malls.
What?
My friends,
though I show your enthusiasm towards getting the people,
it would be better to avoid
as a place of demonstration.
Ah, what pay, but you're probably right.
So what about holding a proclamation on a government building?
It was the Boston,
although I know we want to gather more people to join,
we should not discuss the matter.
There are eyes that might be malicious.
So it's a government building.
He plans stuff, so it's him.
The government, holy, that must be it.
That's through the third bomba.
But which one didn't say?
That's it.
Alright, if that's all we have,
it's what we have to work with.
So let's get the interrogation thing going
before we run out of time.
I'm actually located in the same facility
where Miss Wargay has been detained.
I will have her move to an interrogation room
and walk across to cover my identity.
I will connect to her via a wire.
Let's just hope that you have provided,
gives us enough leverage.
I will open a connection for you to eavesdrop.
After all, this is your case too.
Plus we need all the possible info found.
I'm not ready yet, hold on.
You're like thrusting me into this.
Hostile towards government?
Rejects government.
See, hostile?
I think he rejects.
I'm just going to put rejection.
I have no idea.
Anything else that would become a surprise?
Oh my god.
I'm not ready.
Okay, what's going on?
Right, we're listening to the interrogation.
Stop saying stuff like this.
Don't get hooked.
Who is this?
Why can't you just leave me alone?
Miss Watergate?
My name is Syme.
Great, Symes, can you go-
I already told the other guys everything over and over again.
It wasn't me who hurt the officer.
We have new evidence that states otherwise,
which is why you are in custody.
But that's not what this is about.
We are investigating the bomber at Freedom Plaza.
I just want to ask you some questions.
Cooperate?
Oh god, I cannot read that fast.
Are you joking?
You might reflect positive.
Oh, and you want to frame me?
I've been so busy.
I was right here imprisoned while I did the bomber.
We know you didn't trigger the bomber,
maybe not even the one at Freedom Plaza.
But we do know, however,
you have been in close contact with a group called Thought.
What?
They have nothing to do with this.
I want to talk to my lawyer right now.
You mean that boyfriend of yours?
Joseph Langlin.
My boyfriend?
How do you know that?
We know a lot about you, Miss Watergate.
I don't need to call him then.
No shovel.
Your defiance towards me is not advisable.
What about your parents?
Bruno and Alice?
They've got a nice company, don't they?
Association with a criminal case against their daughter.
Yeah, again, could hurt them badly.
Last time I was in custody,
all they ever did about it was suggesting I'd leave my position.
Does that give you the impression of a perfect family?
Well, have it your way then.
We have your confession in regards to that nasty incident with the police officer.
You'll have to go through the whole process again.
It's gonna drag on for a long time.
And where did you get this supposed confession?
I never did anything.
Miss Carrington stated this in a conversation with you.
Have you been spying on us, you dirty little government?
Well, I hope you also noticed that she started this in defence.
Indeed, we did know that.
That doesn't.
That does mean you have nothing on me.
It seems my colleagues didn't tell you.
You have been arrested as potentially dangerous, did they?
Potentially dangerous.
I like the sound of that.
Me?
Me so dangerous.
This is not a joke, Miss Watergate.
See, it's all in this profile here,
in accordance with the safety bill people have assessed,
as potentially dangerous may be held in custody for a very long time
until they are deemed no longer a threat.
BS, you can't just make something and flag me as dangerous
just because it suits your case.
It's an official investigation result
and we can double that time span.
You'll sit in here with the police record linkers.
No, why?
I hope you will link yourself and your cellmates,
but cooperate and avoid this at once.
Why are you doing this to me?
Just answer my questions
and I might be able to help.
I don't know what you expect from me.
I first went to the Plaza demo.
I don't know much about their plans.
We know that Mr. O'Donnell
had plans to have a kind of proclamation
on the roof of a government building.
Do you know which one?
Government building?
I never heard of anything like that.
I think Miss Watergate,
they have had mentioned anything remotely like that.
Damn it.
I don't know.
There is nothing.
There has got to be something.
Talk!
No, there is never...
I swear, I don't...
This is it, Miss Watergate.
This interrogation is over.
I did not go planned at all, not at all.
I wonder if we went wrong about this place.
Oops.
So what do we do now?
We run out of time and options.
Evacuate just by making an educated guess
that would cause a PR disaster.
We need ideas and fast, else...
I'm sure we're too late.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
We could have prevented this.
Was it the mall?
If only...
I don't know, shit.
There's got to be some serious fallout.
I'll do what I can to keep us in a job.
I think I need fired if it was at the mall.
We need to pull this group apart.
Tomorrow we'll have a serious Nina.
Until then, you're dismissed.
Wait.
Was it at the...
Oops, sorry, wrong one.
It was the mall!
Wait, how is that supposed to pick either or?
Was that supposed to know that he wasn't organizing stuff?
It was the mall.
So it was Nina.
No way I got rolled.
So the conflicting information?
She didn't know Nina doesn't...
Oh, she messed up the organized.
Interesting.
What did she do?
It wasn't Nina.
Rip hot topic, honestly.
You will be missed.
Oh, that's so frustrating.
Okay, I understand.
Anyone knows this game has multiple endings?
It definitely has multiple endings
because I never unlocked the correct ending.
Everything looks fine.
Are you sure?
Yeah, sure.
Whatever I've missed, I've missed.
I got an achievement.
Complete episode 2.
He was...
Okay, so...
We picked up a lot of information.
So we need Nina.
Harrison's been cleared.
Juliet wasn't even a suspect.
Again, Abraham says,
Oh, Nina?
Unperson.
Here we are again after having steered into the bus
not unscathed but alive and still with a job.
I was able to keep us in the business.
My superiors don't want to give up on Orwell just yet.
Needless to say, we cannot
afford to repeat a failure like yesterday.
The TMB is already starting to tear us apart, Lisa!
This Nina character is a final member of thought
and we don't have concrete info.
Since Harrison's plan with the government building
turned out to be a dead end,
we need to get a clearer picture of the loose.
Her stance towards law enforcement
just gives us one more reason
as you found out yesterday.
Focus on Nina, but keep watching all the others too.
Sorry, I kind of thought you wanted to go to my bedtime.
My part.
Hey, forgot to charge my phone last night.
So yeah, I have to do it the old fashioned way.
I really want to thank you for a nice evening.
Only to be topped by that night.
That's it.
I was hoping you'd drop your...
by CCC to come pick me up.
The girl was yammering about...
opposes the safety bill.
Hi, Mark.
Is she be about to come online?
Why would anyone oppose the safety bill?
We have the lowest crime rate in years or possibly ever.
You and me, we have the job thanks to the bill.
The only reason to not support is if you have a dirty, dirty past.
But the situation is here as it is.
It's like someone we should have a very close look at.
We need to fill examination.
First, a concrete background on who.
Second, what motivators.
And finally, where was she around the time of the bomba?
Let's find out.
Where are the headlines?
Catastrophe strikes.
One passed away.
Then for doing a donut time.
Mummy...
Enough of the dirty past.
Let's talk about my dirty future.
Maybe really endangered by lawsuit against the rector.
The surrounding.
The national opinion.
And last week, no.
Predicted assaults only to sell his point to the column.
Condemns the bomba.
Predicts the bomba.
Wait, so what is his stance of that?
A strange way to sell one's point.
It's still peculiarly mentioned bomba before anything happened, but well.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Ah!
So are we creating the scenario from the marrow?
No! Broly legend.
Thank you for the tip.
If it's the marrow or my bad, no.
Prosecure calls on people to take care of their own safety.
Wait, is he completely not going punk anymore?
And he's back to Wolf?
I'm getting confused now.
We cannot save everyone, but we're still a watchful eye on the nation.
Is he completely...
Hey kiddo, you're absolutely right.
One could call that even a mind blown.
But let's not stay at my place tonight.
Okay.
It's unfit for a lady.
No lovers hidden there.
I'm done with her because of...
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
New girlfriend got it.
Thank you sir.
Anina, you mean anything?
Oh, Juliet and Harrison, where'd you go?
That's...
That one's news to me.
Guess it didn't matter.
Now that's over.
Oh, I thought it wasn't.
Anything will set me off.
Angry at birth.
Get angry at birth.
She was my partner in crime a while ago.
I think that's just a saying.
Oh no, it's the only thing I can pick information from, I think.
Making Gen 2 is supposed to be a private affair.
Exactly.
We'll be making it very soon together.
Since then.
Anything?
The edited movie poster.
Oh, go on then.
A hundred gray shadows.
I thought that was going to be a 50 shades of gray.
50 shades of gray.
A hundred gray shadows.
Okay.
Quit fooling around.
War on indifference.
Oh, this is done by Nina.
Okay, Nina, you're going down.
You wait for it.
Just confess, get him.
Right, let me just check.
So, war on indifference.
Indifference towards our own rights is the worst enemy than the government itself.
What?
Okay, so how...
How you in particular incited the crowd to directly threaten the visitors.
Intended to scare them.
You intended to scare them and nuke them?
That was a bit of a miscalculation, was it not?
Scaring people to get attention to one's message, really, is this what thought is about?
You know what I agree with being oblivious in the matter is the problem...
Roots, problem, problem, roots.
We've discussed this many times.
What the heck?
Violence cannot be the key.
Condemned violence, okay.
So Abraham's old school, but Nina...
That was really...
We got a little bit carried away in the info, we're finally getting our message out there.
Now this is recent, Hancock is confusing the crap out of me.
I think he's just getting a paycheck.
She didn't plan to stream today as far as I see, no navigation, okay.
Is Emmy coming on?
Afterwards they're clever and feel sorry about their actions, it's always the same.
I mean, people are allowed to feel remorse.
Stereo.
Unknown person and Nina.
He's still...
Oh, stop giving me new people.
I can't remember everyone.
Just wanted to ask if everyone's fine.
Yeah, don't worry, we're having a great time.
Okay.
Emmy, it comes on in two hours.
Okay, okay, okay.
Thank you for taking care, even though it's Saturday.
Don't mention it, Smile.
How are you feeling?
I think we're gonna have to play the last two chapters tomorrow.
My brain is absolutely killing it.
Nina, I hate to say it, but don't hold it against me, okay?
I'm fine.
Why are you fine?
No, you're not.
You always look so sad.
Often sad now.
That's not anything to do with anything.
No, don't worry about anything new on the love front, no.
God, you're really hard to talk to.
These one...
These like two cents replies are awful.
Only idiots on the singular portal thing you recommended.
Ooh, we might have a connection.
Related document.
Understand we didn't get any risks.
Where?
My dad's so understanding about it, like he took me to a cafe
and I stupidly ordered the fry up thinking it was gonna be like a British fry up.
It was not obviously a British fry up, so I was raging eating it.
Because I was like, why the fuck did I honestly think this was gonna be a real fry up?
Felt like an absolute twat, like of course.
Of course it's not.
Right, singular.
Ooh, don't be single.
Be singular.
Continue to your profile.
This is her.
Oh, you're done for.
We got you.
Oh, we got your height as well.
Oh, it's over for you.
Oh, we know your location.
Oh, it's over.
All is to find a man.
October 1985.
Looking for him.
She's a man.
She's heterosexual.
Oh, sure.
We'll do height for profile description.
Okay.
Hiking, climbing, agent for the wheel.
Suits.
She's doing the bullet.
Late dinner, Stephen Baldwin.
Well, we've got a picture.
Go to Jim.
Jim knows how to train.
What a weirdo.
She's looking.
Your, your opinions.
Ooh.
Financial stability.
How long do you wish for your next relationship to last?
Don't these websites not date to, like, have,
like, a forever relationship?
Am I going crazy?
Would you consider allowing your partner to see other people?
She's sowing in.
Would you consider dating someone who does not want our disliked children?
No.
Oh, she want to birth them babies.
Okay.
What place would you like to go on vacation?
Cities.
Seaside.
Man, countryside.
Cities.
There's so much to do in the cities.
Oh, she polyamorous.
How interested in polytricks are you?
Quite a bit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you a cat or dog person?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I guess cat.
If you turn a, if you turn a left-handed glove inside out, it fits.
Wait, is this a logic question?
Stop, hold on.
If you turn a left-handed glove inside out, it fits the left hand.
Is it still a left-handed glove?
I like the countryside as well.
What are the other questions?
What are you looking for in a partner?
True love, honesty, fidelity?
What's fidelity?
Isn't infidelity what people get killed for?
I'm going crazy.
Social connection, communication, humor, financial, acceptance, openness, independence, casual fun.
Acceptance and true love.
Me and the Wraithling.
Oh, faith.
Oh, well, we ain't checking that box.
Sorry.
I am your, you can have faith in me.
What's this?
Conversate.
To start a new conversation.
Hey, I just saw your profile.
Super Randy.
Why Sam, but not Samwise.
Hi, concerns.
Oh my God.
By the way, it's Molly.
Oh, we've got a name.
We've got a name.
Thank you, Samwise Gamgee.
You helped us progress the floor.
She's using such a peculiar one of that.
Why?
It's my son?
She has a wane?
Or is this fake?
Wait, is this conversation fake?
Hi.
Hi, Sam.
It's Kevin Freshman.
We're going to date.
Just send me to a local Chinese.
I don't care.
By the way, my name is Molly.
You got my Molly.
Oh, maybe she does have a wane.
All right, you got a wane.
A single mother, huh?
Doesn't seem like the type to be involved with such things, right?
What about your conversation with Superman?
Blondie, seriously?
Everyone call me Blondie.
Great, me too.
So where are we going now?
We're not.
Now I totally get why you're there.
You're still single.
I can't believe it.
That's hilarious.
So, I didn't even reply to him.
Well, she didn't reply to him.
What else?
I don't know.
It's a phlegic for her description.
I'll take it.
Does she go to gym?
Maybe she go to gym.
For daily's faithfulness and religious practice or loyal in a relationship.
Oh, Amy published the new ASMR.
I see bloggers.
She's catfishing.
I don't know.
There's something on that page I'm missing.
Okay, I've definitely missed something about your conversations or something else here.
Okay, sure.
Temporary.
Why not?
Oh, God.
May I relay a document?
See, something you think is not logged in on her account.
New profile picture.
Go for it.
See, recent jobs.
What are you being doing?
Has worked in multiple jobs during the week.
But we've not found the conflicting data yet.
We'll work a lot.
We've got an email.
She hit the wall hard.
Reef blend.
She's not supposed to be rude.
Examination.
Dear miss.
Miss Nova.
Just as the prime minister leaves the weather is getting even more.
Cancel the meeting.
He canceled the meeting.
What is that?
What does it mean?
Right, listen.
Nina's got a patient number.
Not a strong word.
There are no pathological findings.
Oh, okay.
She's got blood tests done.
Wait, she's got a new, new name?
Miss Nova.
Ooh, we got it.
We're hacking into her medical database.
This is her private information.
Well, that's where she lives.
I've got her leg.
Perfect.
And address is always helpful.
I've got her leg.
Has injury on life.
Like a medical leave.
I saw a medical leave until April.
Show conflict.
She's been employed.
Pain is mostly due to a prior infected wound.
Compressment damaging.
Sometimes we're similar to those of Mara.
The patient has been strongly advised to favor the leg
to avoid complications.
Prescribe take two times a day.
Advise patient to come back if symptoms don't improve.
I don't know what to do.
That's illegal.
Infidels used by religious people to differentiate
between people who are not part of the religious.
Yeah, I found that.
Hello there little jewel bug.
Welcome to Tech June.
It's so great to hear you.
Yeah, you too.
That's why I called.
It was about time.
Did you know I was working today?
Sorry, I forgot for a second.
You actually know me.
Feeling stressed.
Boss causing trouble.
I can call back.
Oh, no, no, no.
Hanging around the office just as who's, you know,
not to be at home.
I see.
I never got why you moved back and then the first place.
I had to leave my student apartment.
You know that.
And you know that a super lame excuse.
You earned good money at the tech.
Don't you?
You could rent a flat in town.
You just don't want to.
I see you're not going to relent.
Nope.
Sorry.
I had a pretty rough start into this year.
I couldn't really stand being alone at the time.
I feel,
I feel much better now,
but mum, dad, they're so happy I'm back.
I don't want to disappoint them.
Oh, you don't want to.
Yeah.
I can't do that to them.
Not again.
And I hear, I,
and I hear,
I was thinking,
I think that's the wrong spell in here.
I'm like,
I have.
No, you haven't.
You're letting yourself be hassled by mum and dad yet again.
It's the sister.
They're sisters.
Wait, what?
No.
You're letting yourself be hassled by mum and dad again.
What?
I'm so confused.
Yeah.
I'm so envious when dad called you his little June bug.
No, what?
Am I going crazy?
They have two different surnames.
But office is empty.
Yeah, my to-do list is so long.
Okay, let's talk another time.
I will call you again.
Do not try to reach me.
Ha ha ha.
Just kidding.
June?
Yep.
Thank you for holding me.
Aw, look at you sending so seriously.
Wait, am I going crazy?
Who the fuck is June bug?
See you around June bug.
And she's calling her June.
June bug.
What weird nickname is that?
It's just a nickname.
Alia.
What?
Who the heck is Nina?
So why is Nina not getting active?
It's a pretty rough start to this y'all.
I was working today.
June and June bug had their sister through the chat.
Oh, right.
Okay, I knew it.
What are you looking at?
Remarried?
One might be married.
I'm confused.
Sorry, I need to take my bra off.
I'm not comfy.
Sorry to bring that over nowhere.
I'm not comfy in it.
I need to take it off.
Get this bait.
I shed off a bait.
Oh, it's a fucking sports bra.
So it pushes down against my chest when I breathe.
Doesn't one of them have two wings?
Okay, let me hydrate with some water.
Please do hydrate as well.
What we'll do is we'll play until Emmy comes on
or my brain short fuses out.
It turns into a coat wreck.
More like turns into the carpet.
It's on the floor right now.
You got the last two hours for me.
Oh, my reading comprehension is out the window already though.
I think what we'll do, we'll finish up this chapter
and I'll just, I'll redirect into their ASMR video
because it's so cute.
So that's what she said.
So that's what she received,
but we have evidence that we're working.
How could she be working
and she's been given medical leave?
No.
Has worked in multiple jobs during the week.
Right.
Well, unless she's committing frauds.
She may have had an injury, but she's working.
So, so she was working a lot.
Does that account for ability of committing the bomb?
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure either.
Is there something else here?
Sure.
It's still the leg injury.
She may have an oopsie again.
Oopsie, oopsie, oopsie.
That info came in handy though.
Initiate.
Wait, he's talking to her now?
Not in the mood for knock knock jokes.
Oh, you blew it.
Oh, cut the crap.
Who are you?
So now you can't ask.
Initiate is the name in contact with Initiate.
I'm gonna go beat my dad up and tell him to shut the fuck up on the phone.
I quote the other side of this.
Then initiate again.
I wonder what his or her role is.
Well, let's find out.
Initiate has been in contact with two of our target persons so far.
There should be enough.
And here we go.
Feel free to investigate this hacker well,
but keep the focus on the whammin'.
So she's blocked him.
Oh, not again.
You're from Singular, right?
Don't care how you got my number.
Oh, no, that's the one from Session Closed.
Oh, he started up again even though she blocked him?
Yelling your name again?
Oh, he freaking talks to my mum.
And he's like legal name, legal name, legal name.
And I'm like, well, buzz the duck off.
You should listen to me just for a moment, all right?
And then it's all gone.
I don't care what you have to say.
See, I know about your little band of troublemakers,
and I really dig it.
The government,
sorry, I'm gonna make myself a wee bit weird,
so I'm not in the way.
The government needs to know that.
The government needs to kick where the sun don't shine.
So he's anti-government.
Okay, yeah.
That's all right with me, sweetie.
But bombing people, that's plain wrong.
What?
How come you think it was one of us?
Let's just say I've been watching you all for some time.
The bomb bar hit places where your outlawed posse
have been no way you did not hear about that.
You are extremely lucky that the cops were stupid enough
not to have figured that connection yet.
Else they might have prevented the mall thingy.
Me, who could have maybe done the mall thing.
Oh, he misses her here.
How do you threaten me?
I got none.
So give me two reasons.
You know, like,
put your conscience of mine at ease if you want to.
Yolanda, be cool.
I said I want to help after all,
not threaten you.
Her name's Yolanda.
No, her name's not Yolanda.
I'll show you how you do it.
I'm gonna hack that precious page.
And upload something special.
It's gonna be easy with those...
He dares?
Wow.
The it guys are gonna make short work of that rookie.
Don't care about your shit.
Wait, wait, wait.
Sorry, my dad's talking.
We'll have to mute once like...
Oh wait, we'll do this bit
and then I'm gonna fucking go spank him.
Wait, wait, give me a second.
Will I get to work?
Don't go, wait.
If I could get away from you, I could.
I can't switch my phone off now.
That is a nice looking firewall.
You have their dear party web team.
It would be a shame if someone would just bypass it.
Can you actually shut up?
We can't even hear him.
I know, but I'm just worried he like fucking...
You know when like, fuck around the phone
and they wander up and down the hallway.
I'm scared of him doing that.
I'm being right outside the door.
Doing this still gives me chills
and needs to distract myself.
Sheesh, almost done.
Just a second longer.
What the heck?
Oh, shit, man.
They reinforce their huge gaping look.
Oh, it just vanished.
It's almost like somebody warned them.
Yeah, whatever.
Goodbye, initiative.
It's initiate and wait.
I'm gonna spam you for the rest of your day
if you don't answer my question.
It's funny you're watching us when we shower.
You want me to?
Or do you want me to admit to it?
Well, hell, will you leave me alone
and quit poking around my life?
You said you were not involved in this.
Oh, I'm not.
Okay, okay.
Do you think it's someone else?
Thought.
The band of misfits? Nah.
Harrison is the only guy
I could remotely imagine doing anything like that.
Okay, no.
Harrison had an interest in...
Hmm, does she know more than we do
or is it a random question?
Harrison had an interest in Cassandra
because she's got big money.
Sure.
Submit that.
Must be crushing when your friends
only like you for Yamoola.
Juliet was a bit shy, but good at organizing.
So...
You know what I think is the gov themselves?
I love a good self-insert plot.
Sorry, but I'm putting that down.
I thought about that.
Did you know that...
What a joke.
Of course the government
to justify surveillance, right?
I've heard that million times right now.
Every time something happens
there's nothing to these conspiracies.
Did you know that since the
electronic must have unique IDs
they look like this
and it's not even secure?
Well, that's because it is what?
Don't worry, I've only...
Oh, very good.
You've found a device.
Every device in the nation has one in the court
but that's literally what they're talking about.
We can use the insider tool to connect
to see what the user has on the device.
The device must be running it online.
Don't worry, I only access the number remotely.
Nothing more you deserve.
First, you threaten me.
Now this will do.
Initiate recognizes this will help.
His help is not one...
Yeah, if only you would session close.
I can see her desktop.
What's in the trash?
Request for carving jobs.
Okay, so I was right.
She was doing the jobs.
That's fine.
Let me just check all the things in the trash.
Take over the freedom shift.
Oh.
Okay, so no matter how much privacy
you've got, the government already knows.
Put your tinfoil hat on
and let's just call ourselves crazy.
My phone number is a strip.
We've got a phone number as well.
Got everything on her.
Wait, hold on.
Desktop, private.
An apology and an offer.
Oh, okay, okay.
Abraham email.
I'll take it.
Okay, I'll take an email.
I just realized,
have I got green artifact in around me?
No.
I think I'm fine.
Sorry.
When I record, I have to do...
When I record for like shorts, I have to do...
Sorry, that was like jump scare
just out of nowhere.
When I record shorts,
I have to do a transparent layer
and I thought I had it there,
but it's just because I'm so zoomed.
Oh, sorry.
I forget that I'm not supposed to show that part.
Okay, here we go.
Is your hair bun wearing the tinfoil hat?
Exactly.
Look, it fits perfectly.
I suggest that we talk.
Received an offer of assistance by Abraham.
It's in contact with each other.
Okay.
We'll keep that.
Assist each other with what exactly?
Do not read.
I'll embarrass a male.
Pass the part of a relationship?
She's interrel-
So I might as well write down
what I've been trying to say in time.
I love you.
Oh, wait, what?
Every cell in me wants to just backspace
or not send a...
Oh, she's in love with him.
And not just the son,
even though her backpack tripled on him.
Okay, so she's in love,
but he didn't reciprocate
and she spawned a wane because of it.
Like her a-
So she isn't single after all?
She pretends to be?
That's her with a wane.
Desmo?
Yeah, you like that.
Don't you?
Girl, I like your face.
Come again.
Kids being the center of my life.
Squad?
What?
She's an army veteran?
Whoa, but look, the symbol on her tank.
The symbol on her tank
is what she used on the website.
Oh my God.
As an ex-soldier?
We need to specify
specifically know
what kind of experience she has.
That's cute.
Headlines, what's going on?
Headlines, isn't it?
Harrison's timeline?
It's on you here?
That's why you kept it quiet for so long.
What the hell, the big revolution cell
is a lack of peer-to-peer.
I feel you.
When the TNB called on me
and asked if I would write for them,
I laughed in 30 minutes.
But they called me again to let me know
I could write whatever I want.
No strings to hell.
I can even swear, and I do.
Well, good luck with an article like that.
You could not be any further away.
Hmm, so he actually
posted it proudly.
I'm getting so confused with him.
Fuckin' hell, that was her.
What the?
Is that guy from Fende?
He's from Guerrilla.
Nice, it sits there.
Okay.
Well, it's very important to know
we're dealing with a combat veteran.
She's specialised in a few things.
Combat engineer,
bravery medal,
dishonourable discharge
and three months of confinement
for being AWOL
with voluntary return.
That's something to note down.
Absence without official leave.
That's a severe punishment.
Oh, is it?
Because she fell in love with him
and went backpacking with him?
I think so.
Did you know this puts her on the same level
as any previous convicted felon?
Well...
The nation.
Harriers.
Mission kebabs.
Sorry, it does not say that at all.
I'll just check out all the missions
and cases,
something in it,
and it doesn't really look like that.
Engineer, she might know how to pop her.
Oh, actually, yeah, you're right.
I should write that down.
Write that down, write that down!
Okay, so there's nothing.
Okay.
Let's do the news.
Wait, no, let's do her.
Of course, I can't even find it now.
Memorial.
Oh, this is sad.
Her boyfriend passed away.
That explains why she's a single mother.
Initiated by the government,
as much as I hate to say it,
it definitely provides motivation to hate it.
Find more to back that up.
Aw, that's really sad.
Oh dear, oh dear, oh dear.
Right, let's report that you are a combat engineer.
Same year as her discharge.
Okay, so...
Well, you know that she got the bravery.
Ward, at least.
And if he says it's a waste of time,
he can pop his clogs.
Seems to have come a long way
from being such an honorable person.
There's something on the missions that I missed.
I've missed something on this page, apparently.
I don't see it.
It's here.
What one is it?
I'm scrolling, asking for the game to do it for me.
Oh, there we go.
Task with infrastructural maintenance during a thingy,
but it's conflicting with something later.
Why does this keep being highlighted?
Previous entry.
That's why she's ill.
Like, she's got issues,
because she's...
Patient reports a permanent unrest
that's suffering from...
Patient tends to react aggressive when challenged.
She has PTSD.
Oh, right.
Report the PTSD, because that's dangerous.
PTSD is unbelievably dangerous.
That sounds menacing and important,
but I wonder what might have caused it.
Well, she's a veteran.
She's seen war?
Hello?
Are you serious?
I wonder what caused it.
Oh, look at that.
So, how do we find what was conflicting in French, you know?
I don't know what conflicting...
I love how the music changes every time something shocking
and important happens at school,
not shell-shaped.
And I probably heard her boyfriend perish in front of her.
Mmm.
She's covered wars, you know.
Exactly.
I can't find this...
other thing that conflicts with this.
Hmm.
I'm missing something.
I'm missing a lot of things.
So, the mission's got the conflicting thing.
So, what's in here?
Yeah, it's up 5 to 12 times an hour,
but does not feel overly tired.
I mean, I'll just assume a lot of things.
There's something I'm missing.
Is there something I'm missing?
I think I'm missing something.
Ugh, nonsense.
Is there anything else on this piece here?
Oh, wait.
I don't know what this is.
System.
Oh.
CCTV.
She looked up CCTV.
Hmm.
If we had a video...
of Strone dying,
we would have cried till the end of the stream.
I watched Azura finish a...
stray,
and like her voice sounded quite sad.
Me, who like burst out in her tears,
like, ohhhh!
I really am the crybaby.
I was like, oh, this is the saddest thing I've ever played.
Ohhhh!
Like, greeting Miza.
And Azura's just like, yeah.
Oh, that's sad.
Yeah, Azura's way stronger.
That's another thing to start from.
You have something sinister in mind.
Not to be confused with the...
the head beach of our sin sister.
Yeah, we want something sinister.
It's vaguely associated, you know,
with the soul.
This makes two locations.
We will have a very solid case,
so if we can make a third...
singular thing, you're in.
Momè.
Yeah, we can move on.
Okay, I don't think there was anything else we could extract out of this stuff.
Right.
There's something con...
there's something...
projects.
It has become mandatory to inform employees
whenever an applicant applies an ex-convict.
Safety Bill prevents Nina from getting a job.
Huh.
So as you're considering she's on her own taking care of her son,
it makes one hell of a motivation together
with the fact Desmond was killed on a mission.
Congrats, every name's Desmond!
By the government.
We have found a strong motivation revenge.
But we haven't found the conflicting piece of information
with this one here!
Please!
What's the conflict?
I can't find it.
No.
Task with infrastructure maintenance.
Hmm.
It's an on-tri-PC.
Where's it on your PC?
Do not read infrastructure.
Do not read...
There's not going to be any active emails in it, is there?
An earlier blog post.
Let's have a little...
scramble through this.
Hmm.
What can I access?
Everything's archived on one page.
Bye.
I'm just checking if there's anything new that is...
reachable.
That doesn't really seem like it.
Wait, what's the date in the letter?
I'm pretty sure she wrote that after he died.
It's probably...
grief written letter.
There's a lot of grief.
Desmond Miles from the hit video game Assassin's Creed franchise?
Hmm.
I'm being pepega.
I don't know what it is.
I was checking out the jobs she could get.
8 bucks an hour, that's rubbish.
I don't want to do all the profile dumbass.
Maintenance, works in cleaning maintenance.
She can repair stuff.
See recent employee feedback.
We already submit for this.
Hmm.
I'm shy to this game.
I don't know if I should just submit the one I can find,
because I can't seem to find the other one.
No.
These are like such arbitrary...
notes.
I'm definitely...
I'll just submit the job one.
Why not?
Right there, boom.
You do all that.
Upload complete.
Okay, she's a handy handy gal.
I'm not sure.
You can work tons of nights and stuff.
I don't know.
Look at us working on the weekend.
I get it.
It's different, of course, when you're single, mother.
That must be tough.
Do you have any idea why she's doing this?
What she aims for?
Sun, sun, high table.
Something, something, high table.
Oh, so you can use it.
I am very E.P.
I am God's E.P.S. soldier for today.
For once, it's not AC is the E.P.S. soldier.
Did AC end up streaming?
I knew she had a migraine.
I don't know if she ended up finishing up.
No, right.
I'm doing it.
I'm sending it.
I can't seem to find wherever the conflict and information is,
so I'm just sending it.
So nothing noteworthy here.
We know, we know, know enough,
of our background.
Was it another mission?
It was probably another mission.
A3.
AC can't migraine to buddy.
Yeah.
Yes.
Hey again, self here.
How's it going?
You feeling better?
Yeah, somewhat.
Finally, after spending the whole last week in bed.
Oh God, I can bring Michael around though.
Do you want?
No, thanks.
I'm going to pick him up in an hour.
Would that be okay?
Yeah, of course.
I promise to go to the playground with him.
That's fine.
I'll pick Michael up from the corner at Orchard Drive.
A location?
Oh, we've got a location if we need to arrest her.
No!
That's such a good donor.
No, that's such a good donor.
Thank you, the disco opinion.
Option, sorry, not opinion.
The disco opinion.
Option, fuck.
The disco option.
Thank you for the tip.
Sorry, I'm out.
Super chat shit.
I'm fucking losing it.
Okay, that might play a role there.
That was such a good donor.
Right, we've got spending in bed last week.
I feel that's conflicting.
We would like to inform you about new rate
in McDougal Groundkeeping Services.
Yippee!
She was apparently there at the mall.
So she worked at the site and even at the right time.
She's worked at the right time at the other location.
We have now been able to associate her with every location.
Her whereabouts are hereby clarified.
Things are not looking good for her.
That's it.
You've found all we need to know.
Let's see.
Myth, matter, nova.
Simply engaged in maintenance tasks in the military.
That doesn't seem notable.
There's evidence that she has strong relations
to hate the safety bill.
And finally, we can associate her with every single
bomb location to prove that she was present.
Seems we've found her prime suspect.
This is ground for arrest.
I will need a moment to talk to my superiors.
I'll get back soon.
Keep observing, however.
There's something here I've missed.
But I don't.
Oh, what's she doing?
Yeah, I've got a PC.
What are you doing?
What are you trying to hide?
What's your search history?
No.
Oh, sugar.
She's talking to her synodona.
Hey, Harry.
Are you there?
Oh, please.
Is my name Ebenezer Scrooge?
Why do all the ghosts in Christmas Pass
come back and haunt me?
Harry, I don't have time for this.
I have a problem here.
I need your tech knowledge for.
Why doesn't anyone ever ask me about my problems?
Oh, right.
Why is it?
I just came home.
Da, da, da.
And I had left my PC switched on this morning
and I just tried to look something up online
and suddenly it went all hair wire.
And my security app popped up with like a million
warnings from some intrusion.
So I pulled the plug.
Oh, no.
Sounds like you already fixed the problem then.
The thing is, I got contacted by a very strange guy earlier.
I think he was some kind of hacker.
And now he's hacking my PC.
Geez, this guy is a new aunt.
New aunt.
New...
New sense.
Oh, my God.
I think that guy already broken to my bank account as well.
Oh, no.
It's us.
We're the baddie.
I wonder who does it.
I was contacted by that guy as well.
He was blabbering about everything that we'd done in the past.
And he would give our stuff away to the cops as usual.
He told you that as well.
What did you do?
I told him that.
F off.
Who do you take me for?
Do you think he really has something?
I need to be sure he doesn't have a thing.
Even if that guy had something,
have you gotten your hands dirty?
What's the fuzz about?
Who even says that?
I need to get out of here before the cops are here.
Whoo!
Uh, she's what?
We cannot let her main suspect.
I will assemble an intervention team immediately.
We'll start creating mobile.
I'll form the intervention team that they should move in aggressively.
As you find out, she might react violently.
Since her PZ has gone offline,
we should start at her home.
Thankfully, we're already in our dress.
Go through her communications.
Maybe she will hint at places she's going that ain't home.
Forward anything of importance to me.
It's in your hands now.
Don't mess this one up.
We can't afford it after the last incident.
Oh, come on.
This guy's faking.
Hello, is anyone there?
Figures.
Team Alpha Bravo Charlie, move, move, move.
Oh, she's in call to her sister?
Is she going to go to Juliet's?
Welcome to Tech U.
Oh, hey, Juliet.
Thank God you're working right now.
I called your mobile, but couldn't get hold of you.
Can we talk?
You know, I'm all alone here catching up on work.
Is everything okay?
Listen, I don't have much time.
Okay.
There is this psycho that's coming for me.
He's been stalking me.
Wait.
She thinks the psycho's coming for her?
I can't explain.
Will you help me?
Of course.
But how?
Do you know somewhere safe that my son and I can lay low for a while?
Wait, she thinks the psycho's coming after us.
Not us.
Wait, but did Nina do it?
I don't think Nina did it.
Come on.
You got to think.
Okay.
I think I know a place.
It's in the middle of nowhere.
She could be lying.
No, wait.
Don't say it.
I think he might be listening.
What?
How?
This guy is a hacker.
He's already gone through my computer and I'm pretty sure he's listening to my call.
She knows the call.
So are you kidding me?
I mean, like, listen right now.
Just don't say anything that will give my location away.
Okay.
Better safe than sorry.
Just help me get out of here.
Bit late for that now.
Now he knows where I work.
Sorry.
Okay.
Let's just get out of here.
Thank you.
Give me a sec.
Just going to pack some stuff.
Did Nina know where she was?
I'm bringing my gun.
Squad team, I repeat.
I repeat.
Boogie is hot.
She's armed.
I didn't expect that.
I'll tell the intervention team.
Yeah.
Boogie is hot.
We're changing.
Someone listening to this.
Your arm.
Yeah.
And if I don't get protection, I'm going to be dead anyway.
Someone's at the door.
She's at the back door.
Okay.
Come on, squadron.
She went out of the back.
She's a flight.
Maybe she'll climb out the window.
Hold up.
Is everything all right?
Damn.
Nina.
No, no, no, no.
He spotted me.
Isn't that our task?
He knew I was climbing out the window.
How?
Okay.
Nina.
What the heck are you doing?
Not going down without a fight.
That's what.
Is she?
What?
Why are you fighting?
Don't fight.
Make sure you look more sus.
You're not going to get.
Nina.
who's right and at the worst I just want to be done with this horrible day can
you check the mail please who's right and who's right and what do you mean
who's right and what's now
Abraham Nina I'm truly sorry the investors but to be frank you overstepped
the boundaries of the bombs were meant as a warning for those who are different
oh she's perished a beacon they were not meant to kill oh my god I can't believe
you just went to sit can you they work together but why I still don't get it
this changes everything we must find Abraham tomorrow before we'll need the
rest it's been one hell of a day they were not meant to kill I mean even if
they were not meant to kill so fucking crap you joking me that women lost our
life and it was you do you honestly believe that after all you've seen oh the
bombs were meant as a warning they were not once again you disappoint me with
your instrumentable hatred and rage consider our agreement boy what oh my
gosh complete episode 3 that was insane he set her up actually
oh my god episode 4 memory hole
oh back again well yes my job and it clocking for my shift I still can't
believe what happened we got the perpetrator the bomber everything looks
that way but at what cost I mean did we do the right thing flag and miss as
dangerous did we kill her in the end I wish you could talk to me at least this
one time speaking into this one-way channel feels like barking at a wall
endlessly worst of all as you found out Abraham seems to have incited and planned
the assaults we need to get him today there must be some lead on him we have
overlooked we'll keep observing all others in case we learn of something new
okay let's see what the headlines are a legend perpetrator is dead
listen I don't like the reports either we need to cover the fact that this
happened somewhere else we cannot frighten people sometimes their truth
and ours have to divert for the common good oh they're framing on her yeah
Donald's weekend Harrison this is oh my god her sister just perished isn't this
your office number I appreciate I'm once again important Harrison Nina is dead
quit bullshit me not funny take a look at the TNV if you don't believe me my
god what she's been associated with the bomb and I can't believe it Nina you
stupid piece of what in the hell there's more I spoke to her yesterday she
called me I've never heard her so scared she said she was being tracked by
someone and needed to skip town sorry I need to hydrate she just wanted to let
me know what was going on in case anything happened to her then packed a
few things went on her way she did message me about someone tracking her
as well though it was this hacker who screwed with her page what did she tell
you she suspected someone to be wiretapping her calls she wasn't
exactly willing to talk about it I don't know for sure but I think it could
have been the police oh this is brilliant how long until they discover the
connection to us they might be listening to this very call as we speak about
Nina why would they we didn't do anything or did you know but it's
becoming blatantly obvious those governments are trying to set us up the
bombs were exactly where we held our protest then those letters with em
believes the government wants to set it up that's the second time and now you
tell me you've been in contact with Nina yesterday seems to be that they must be
setting us up because we didn't do anything for sure I almost understand it
almost the fourth wall speaking up against them too many times I don't know
hmm we should seek help just in case help who's gonna help us Joseph Langley the
lawyer yeah the boyfriend a lawyer what do you want him to do bus law
enforcement the government he understands our situation Abe also knew Joseph I
thought I didn't know that they knew each other hmm brah really Joe's they make the
law they break the law they know each other very well this could be a new
lead I will request Joseph yeah another person because we're so convinced we're
doing the right thing huh we have cleared to proceed we are going to need to know
some basics on who Joseph Langley is remember to check old sources other than
that focus on hints of Abraham he's the center oh god I can't read that fast he
understands it really they make the law so yeah take it you got a better plan we
need to get people on our side turn things around Abraham knew that yeah
you're right he did know that so now you've set on miraculously achieving
something the thought spent one and a half years this is not about the thought
this is about me defending myself well then what's your defense plan there is a
guy a guy goes by the name initiate might actually be a girl who cares look
the hack on this thought blog is very elaborate our site is super safe I'm not
an amateur that guy girl whatever is skilled and initially mentioned having
no sympathy for the government you're gonna trust a random hacker who targets
thought simply because he said he doesn't like the government why would he
first threaten us and they've worked with us just leave it to me Joe leave it
to me all right tails there you come leave it to me I'll persuade initiate
with ease imagine the possibilities with their own okay you know what have it
your way I'll have it main arguing like the good old days it's your might be more
secure than calling it brother how is that more secure you've just handed it
over to me okay there you go let's get going there goes my Sunday morning watch
yourself okay my mind is spinning what happened to Nina you watch yourself what
are you worried about me Jill's I don't know you so no bye sorry for that join
forces what he wise ass I know for a fact that you were messing around and
become a member of thought huh huh would you like to join us mr. hacker man I
wish my way I miss my wife I love that thing I thought mr. Donald left thought
now he seems like he's recruiting makes his exit seem unlikely so they put her
up as the bomba when confronted by the special forces and you know drew a
firearm fired the team returned to killing
well there's our lawyer we can start collecting stuff on him Sandra you so
by the way I'm going to see your contact in a very casual manner I like how
they didn't break up either multiple homicide when prompted to surrender the
suspect instead showed out aggressively while producing a firearm aiming at one
of the agents the suspect then opened fire wounding several agents on the
show oh wounding special agent on the shoulder and defense draws pistol and
returned fire as the situation briefing had already suggested to proceed with
caution the suspect was hit in the chest causing her to collapse an ambulance
was called but paramedics cannot resuscitate due to injuries in
kvatsa bowl with la ha ha always got a weak girlfriend
I have no idea for me is it all something about Paul against sentient
EI update on the party I don't know I don't know why this had an update thing
right headlines what we're not terrible this heavy rain oh no exclusive
interview with Jim founder Ronson oh yeah gotta get super right this is red so
I assume there's something in here maybe comes up later fast precise honest mm-hmm
sure let's read the car article I do love and though love reading a bit of
car okay there's a star there there's also star admissions still what did I
miss there's literally nothing I missed here
there's nothing I can click on the army page
so must be something weird cuz it insists there's like a piece of
information about Nina here but to be honest you can't have popped her clogs
so it's kind of over before it started maybe it comes up we already we got our
information that we needed it was all a dream and they woke up so if I close
these will that only show me the ones that might have something I feel like
okay yeah I was gonna say I feel like I've got like so many pages what's this
oh oh it's you oh that's right everyone said that you were a student well
that was some time ago wasn't it was rest of the new for all not self-employed
graduated right so there's a connection between them to go we're getting there
allow me one yawn please right we'll just upload any information we find cuz
oh I've really a dog to mature has his own law so we just unlocked his wee
website I think so welcome oh my god it's me I thought that said something else
there profile after my release from prison I got involved what another full
of them now you're making me on to oh yeah you're loving so much you're gonna
yarn and reciprocate to show that you're sympathetic towards me he partnered
with Catherine De La Croix a fellow shouldn't sure sure you're got a joke
on what did you standing there wow I didn't even know she had a locker you're
going before she joined politics mr. Langley definitely has been around the
block I'm still I'm still so far so good on mr. Langley excluding the
connections to De La Croix everything's on the prison what we need to know right
now are his connections to Abraham and possibly the other members your broad
military service my Nina no I did I mean there's any combat experience look
I'm just checking it out you're safe oh she's phone in my phone friend hello am I
talking to you said hydration check burp reciprocate when you burp a burp into
your mouth and you burp it back into mine you taste my chicken breath actually
had steak last night my dad I heard from Cassandra I'm sorry I didn't get
back to you really that's good where she in jail it's not good she got arrested
what's why she's trying I didn't need this burp in dress waiting till I upload
that I was informed Cassandra's been taken in because apparently they have new
evidence regarding the attack on the officer I tried to call me Julie but
they claim she didn't want to talk to me that's their official statement where did
they suddenly dig up new evidence from you Juliet you're the problem I've
uploaded an audio yes already on patreon it was like a like a milestone
thank you and it's just me chugging colon water and burping use of the sadly
aligns perfectly with another incident you probably read the TNB today you
mean about the bomber yeah that woman that died Nina she was a friend she was
a friend and all I was just guess that she was there and a member of the group
called thought oh no I'm sorry I had no idea but reflands were women it's okay
you pause you can have known your rate this is very troubling I'm not getting
evil vibes from Yosef come to think about everyone asked me a favor and
called Nina sometime ago I hope that wasn't nice might well be I doubt Abe knew
about other folk name you know a favor for her this could be important follow
that lead I was just a small thing nothing of importance oh oops I spoke to
Harrison and remember the group we agreed the police might be investigating us
next they might be onto everything and thought they might lock us up straight
away I mean can they do that well even with the safety belt in place they
still need solid indication that you're involved in the actual bomber although
honestly I'm not sure what constitutes a solid indication these days is there
anything we can do that you can do maybe I think it's all girl I'm gonna check the
audio instruments really appreciate you come to me it really is wearing and I
would take this on immediately wear it not for Cassie I made the mistake of set
I hope Cassandra primarily concerned again Cassandra released I mean that's a
new thing Yosef Nina's dead she got shot there's no time for next oh well oh
well I thought it was oh well no it's oh well there's a pause okay I need time to
read into some more specialized codes of law again write some emails see if
there's a legal limbo or basically anything I can do for Cassandra maybe
I'll come across something that may help you as well after all these cases seem
connected I hope you understand I do it's kind of a relief thank you I wish I
could do more I'll let you know okay bye bye goodbye Juliet
join forces troubling very trouble I'm sorry for what happened but answering
this how can I join what I'm already a part of it send me your answer he's
already in it wait you're trolling us then you're trolling us what's this web
warrior he is a member already why didn't think any hints of the history it's a
pug I can't really put a pug as a picture status friend me to get express
curate for news points it's good for some time on sure these birthdays are
fake and are in training them at this is all fake and so it begins the web warrior
hereby to clear the day of war on all day of wars with day of war tell apart
radio okay so community listen initiative I made a little game it's called at horn
versus horns and it'll be available for everyone to play soon as they don't play
drop me a line you get invited to the beta naturally no I got I've got to be
it I am not into none of the memes again I am not into today open letter to Victor
Rosson your week though I got a glimpse of the ivory tower was at the building my
nickname for science reasons so you sure I'll add it to the profile I mean I guess
I'll add that he's close hi Leah you mean sister in law that what what name thank
you for becoming a member I appreciate it please enjoy your moats as well there's
new moats on the way they're coming merci first of course he would have gone
there everyone I know who's remotely an attack wants to work there which is quite
mind-boggling they actually have a lot of interns and only very few people ever
get in thank you for coming a member and shuffling me expertise that you can
rely on for jury and fraud identity theft copyright infringement this is all
just what he's been doing you said you took on defense for Hendricks which
was able to convincing argue that Hendricks had actually acted on behalf
of the transport I don't know why any of that means or well try yes I remember
yeah I remember perfect no way anyone missed that case that was either courageous
or dumb seemingly it turned out to be the former for some time now it might be
the latter
route is similar to admin in most systems up route means to blank someone in
Aussie land rustic thank you for becoming a member please enjoy your moats and
thank you for the direct support as always that helps out I can't wait to
I'm not gonna do the year bro that was bizarre and yes there's a lot of fun
things being planned and coming up soon to you and we'll add his number and stuff
our office and one office address as well did I start a membership train a
little baby but thank you your kindness is always appreciated difference between
courage and stupid is the results right so he's already an urgent request can
you please unlock the ID please excuse me I have an urgent matter oh there was
the one thing I need to mention the head engineer warned me that apparently
there was a glitch causing devices to malfunction at times you wouldn't the
issues being fixed so now it's undetectable I'm in a position just of
as requested by unknown person to deliver information
it's getting and we love me some score I'm from Ireland are you kidding me this
is our hacker friend wait well I'm in a position if I don't
get in commute for a person named members of her mind being contacted with
going on in these emails you said it's done don't work too much love burn who's
lover I will deliver additional information on members of the activist
group thought admitted agreed to submit information on thoughts and unknown
person I've not been in contact for a long time I can't meet your demands yeah
she died I didn't expect him to give in so let's wait and see what's going on in
this PC of yours right we can get in for free
sorry I was about to cough sorry I just randomly go I was about to cough but
I managed to stop it hold on let me let me have a drink of water do apologize
please hydrate little reflash so sorry
he's a rat is he
oh I need to hydrate my little throats uh feeling it mr. crabs
yeah this is cleared cleared by user it's not quite how it works but he will
pictures what we got an active support of a foundation
he's married in 1993 he got married a trout
profile update oh they were spotted together that's quite big news
I will change a bit to the one we've been spotted together dancing in the
is that no
that's not who I think it is no kind of system what's in the trash folder nothing
mail office request concerning investigation custody of my client
okay so he is actually trying to get our feedback on your request
financially troubled laying off mrs considered laying off mrs winners as an
employee related profile mrs went to create a new
profile sure why not
uh ugly but not of our concern oh right okay well sorry I was just trying to
cover all my asses I did not have the capabilities required to
rejected a recent case for two cents due to missing
bank account ooh I don't mind if I do
where's the sugar daddy have you seen Austin powers I haven't but I want to
watch it with you guys
um
I'm very excited there is so much going on I don't I can hardly give up right I've
read all the office ones now for private I need to ask you a favor
our dear fellow in Dubu Dubu in Dubu
that's his alias in Dubu I never friends maybe this friendship is worth
investigating due to asking you about ongoing
foreign national support for Nina asses was okay there's a young woman named
Cassandra to defend Cassandra okay the wonderful job
you did in my case has been legally defended him
I guess
so this is why they knew each other Abrams a client
which raises a question what was his case about
should we find out I've not the wait it's actually called sundown fishing
club wait oh it's an ad for a big pharma okay
oh yeah remember the environment king fisher
oh yeah gallery comment by king fisher by fishing for
compliments in dubio well we know who in dubio is
he's so good no I love it I am the quote
like some people are just happy doing nothing who's
who are you new portrait of Abraham
Abraham I've got a new four of you awesome first trilogy would be perfect
I was actually thinking we'd watch um
uh who would we watch
Abraham is gay what the fuck yes friend told me practically asked him out by
proof enough that Abraham is gay who cares
now I get why your wife divorced you it all makes sense you're not like
why are they arguing over fish what just happened
are we arguing over fish
shut the fuck up oh my god just that is hilarious I'm sorry that's the funniest
thing I've seen it's a fish website we start arguing about the
reason why your life your wife left us because you're a gay man
well I just caught a bass I just wanted to show the size of it
oh my god okay accused of breaching the terms of employment contract with a
plaintiff so don't we breach a working contract
with the government oh that could be motivation why it
doesn't like the government I'll take it I'll take it
work for the government are you positive this is a true surprise I've
never heard his name here never someone must know of him
why was he sued over breach of contract oh my god
get sued for breach of contract and wait why did this happen
naturally I refused to turn down a work contract from the government
it's not really much to go off of is it
the plaintiff was granted inflicted by a medical condition
huh well they'll get him over it the fish is worth the smoke
this seems to spend a lot he felt too sick for work tried to get out was charged
for it and instead was found guilty considering the fact the bombings are
starting to look like a very weird vendetta high time we fined him
what is going on oh we've got a medical right well we've got an address already
what's the deal address well done I'll request a team to invent
somehow I doubt he's around continue work on notify even the team gets back
okay so this is a state of birth we're just going to fill in out the old
profile right relationship uh apparently
here's a tumor oh
that's kind of sad
there a point of putting that down I mean I guess just be easy on the man if
you find them oh cancer yeah just if you do find
them just go easy on them
the average life expectancy
okay so he doesn't expect to live long maybe he wants to make a change on his
we owe this is harsh but does this mean it means he has
nothing to lose yeah hmm I I concur why is this red
salaries
invoices
invoice
uh headlings why is headlings
I assume something new will pop up if I like don't mess up the
headlings but I keep messing it up so it's not working
okay let's see what's going on here I'm unexpected proposal fine I'm
not sure I refuse just refuse
is he pro is he probably looking to break bad
I don't know what the reaction is to that joke so I'll let you guys figure out
goldfills refuse that first then take the contract only to breach it how
I mean does it matter if he's you know
what is the conflict
I'm married I mean does it is he married no the other person that's 19 show the
conflict and then this is 2005
okay so this is the truth one on whoever on yosef this is the truth one on him
because that thought was from ages ago
I don't think we should mess with private life okay sorry sorry I was just
getting I don't know I don't know what you want okay
head headlines keeps being read
right initiate is just a troll play again again again
go fail what did I miss here that he was abroad that's so specific I mean
put him in case that and pops up got a snip I gotta go soon I hope you
read the rest of your shingles oh thank you for hanging please don't worry if you
have to go at any point I'm gonna try and redirect into
emi and I don't think I'm gonna finish up this
chapter and then I'll redirect into emi's ASMR video so you're all forced to
watch it and okay I'm very clearly messing this
up I think
I think I'm messing it up I'm not actually sure
what it wants me to do other than to like smack in
all right
like warrior the web profile picture is obviously not a pug the birthday is
obviously wrong he's not ancient the omnipresent interwebs no interest in
interting like none of this is anything
hmm
so then what's in the gallery there's something else here
club
uh contact is responsibly 25 dollars you already said the last chapter
probably look at the last article the gem one
it's just this is
really you must be kidding I do not do Russian
what is going on is there like a listen conversation
is it something I'm not sure whatever try and get Cassandra out
no I didn't do anything if I'd be trying to get my girlfriend out too
yeah careful now you're starting to sound a little sympathetic
mister don't tell me you've changed your
oh whoops there's something important in here
uh no there's no
that's the only thing that's not important
wait is it the same night of the bomber
I don't know why it was red right what have I not reported on in this
conversation you're working sure
I'm sure it's so important to write down that she's working
I have truly so important call the fisherman
cheer man wait sorry call the fishing clubs
cheer man exactly right I've done all the listener stuff
I've done all the insider stuff unless this is it which is really random if
this is it
I've been skipped school but they've been officially proved as a benefit I
guess that's good
is it okay you look some love and not full
I already claimed it in the waiting
ah whoever hmm system breviser he's cleared it
pictures I've just checked mails let's just go to them again
financially trouble doesn't change a thing
okay sure he rejected a case
I already submitted the wedding poll because he was getting roasted on that
fishing website for it like I'm not even kidding
he's married a conflict with another thing
this guy was like being really rude but I already submitted
but the game was like almost sexual no no one cares
that's not got anything to do anything
so feedback on your request
I'm about to start shopping everything in the freaking
thing right device offline I need to ask your favor
okay sure let's do the favor stuff
and the circle is complete well is it or
isn't it he may have supported the bomb bar
I don't know if that oh that was it oh crap hold on Harrison Harrison
hi wise ass anyone there
so you find your way here Harrison check his bank account and find out why he's
broke oh I forgot about that because we never found
digging through your timeline was a pain in the ass why didn't you just tell me
you wanted to chat when you told me what happened to me now I went
straight on to research I got the impression that the
government is up to no good great work captain obvious
I did find something something you won't like a bit
or well oh no he knows he knows he knows he knows
oh no we did everything to keep it outside of the nation
and now it's unfortunate people have become aware of it ahead of its time
we must tread very carefully we will not speak so openly any longer I fear
seems it's a system that can put everything on the web under surveillance
what do you mean everything in this every way maybe pcs whatever your bs in
me I'm not man I'm not I wish I was
title drop he said the game name
that's the same for a secret how do you pull this off storage alone is one
thing that I've been going through all of it
the outsource surveillance to people outside the nation
am I outside the nation oops those people are supposed to collect pieces of
data from websites all kinds of communication whatnot and send it to
Orwell it's safe to assume that nothing is safe anymore
wait so can I not report properly how come you never heard of it even more
importantly how come you have
uh I have very good connections to some hackers outside
the nation I don't know if I can report that or not
the new thing or two about secret I mean it's information
that spins what happened to Nina a real hacker now unfortunately we can't go
after people outside the nation so we don't even have the right to do it
do they have no decency no respect Harrison don't
yeah this is everything we fought again you need to watch your tongue
oh is there about to say something I don't need to watch my tongue
it's already being what please chill out or we will regret it
oh I'll never chill again unless this madness stops
I already got an idea Taylor made for you
man if you discuss things like this here you'll get us both locked up
let's meet somewhere then
yeah and say the word and they'll be there in two
oh they'll be there too
there must be something we can just talk without the possibility someone
snooping around we can't stand and do nothing
there's one thing it's a bit risky
are you using my chat till right now is this week well if I want to live in
life in a cage I go down in no so the system needs yeah
it's abominable but yeah um this tool has a bill inside for
oh we're not going to be able to see it
it's a custom encryption algorithm written by me easy to break but off
record and that's what we need they'll probably
kind of break this not right way give us a couple of messages probably what are
you waiting for go for it is it gonna work
I'll activate it now just remember to write quickly
and keep your fingers crossed it'll work oh it works
I'm getting reports of unknown don't worry Orwell should be able to break the
encryption in mere second
I mean is it
I'm going to meet you in the coffee shop at three you wink wink
and before it's html encryption it could work oh it's already broke
I will need some time to localize the intro and then I'll only have second one
thing what will you do with what I find there
start a war on the government
is he actually going to do that or is the old gas no break
is the old breaks no gas
oh well okay fine oh shit they actually mean it okay uh
time to get to work yeah we're gonna have to report that one chief and we'll
be honest if he wants a war well he shall have one we will
have mr odono rested long before I can obtain that
the national beholder just published oh best see for yourself
what
how are they aware of the thought we never report I imagine you're looking
my way now aren't you I have absolutely no idea who leaked this info
certainly not me only very few people can access the date on our back end this
doesn't exactly a dozen investigation quite the office that we need to hurry
freedom is unfree
oh no
oh no they're both kicking off are you doing
what's going on here right the bank reoccurring donation
oh naughty man naughty naughty naughty naughty
these look poles I've had enough of them
deliberately hard to get them to quietly when they're at the center of a
right haha so there may be something in connection between
Yosef and Nina after all if you can find one last
indication that this may be meant for Nina
be enough to get custody
and say there what's going on here feedback on your request
there then there's this reoccurring donation that's been going on I can
respect if you want to help out a friend or something
but we need a reply
the certificates issued outstanding ongoing
so tax evasion are helping out a pal what one is that
excuse me for sending like these are major issues to see apart from the
number of clients drop on steadily your expense
since the end when especially the credit card went up by a whopping
any idea the reason but you stopped at some point seriously
if all those expenses are a must well I would definitely agree with laying off
the person that's what I'm thinking it's a
not a real charity no there's no way he's sending money
to his pals not the certificate he's embezzling money
oh that's what the payments are for yes oh no
oops I thought it was going to be obvious it's embezzlement
wait isn't it embezzlement
your entanglement about the immediate termination of work regarding
ah he got laid off you mentioned you've been participating in suspicious groups
and activities that's funny I think I'll submit that the wrong way around
we picked the wrong one sorry I submitted the wrong way around I'm sorry
I'm too slow IQ okay hey hey hey seems the government just fired the
fresh shots our way seems so
I thought they might take longer to trace all back to thought I didn't expect
that it'd be openly right about it
hmm
they fired me hee hee I'm not surprised
ipsy whoopsie just ruined the plot ipsy whoopsie
well accident no there's this thing cast has been arrested her lawyer told me
what uh baby girl
just as I thought it couldn't get any worse yeah but
it was about new evidence in the officer's injury
not the bomb the look like the eucliness is heading her way
think the police will follow this lead to of course it's just a matter of case
don't you I'm gonna go to bed in a minute
okay I promise I'll cuddle up on your chest and I'll just go
on top of you and then you just pet my hair and I'll fall asleep like I can't
Harrison I'm scared yeah don't be did the hacker say something
oh that
he's typing he's typing this guy's crazy I don't know why I ever thought of
asking him don't get your hopes up oh he's playing mega safe not telling
Julie it what about the lawyer seems like we will have
use for him soon Joseph says he's busy trying to get
Cassandra out that's Sanova understandably so
what would you do if whatever her name was arrested huh
what would you do if I was sorry just hit my knuckles on the table if I got
picked up yeah yeah get it you don't need to
to lecture me Jill's but you said did see
he might give us advice if he finds anything yeah of course he will right
after he sends us his invoice that's not fair
we got face up we're on our own oh wait the concert is tomorrow or something
I should have done the wrong day is it today I better not be today I'm sure
no no no I did it on the right day it's 10 a.m on the 15th
because I made sure I linked it up yeah beat that desk up show him his book
yeah he just just takes me give me a second
did he add to it
it's the 12th today concerts in three days
you see this is the thing you can't mention you're tired or
or your body's like did you say tired okay let's shut down there's like no no
I'm still streaming please just give me like 10 more minutes 10 more minutes
please okay we'll finish this game tomorrow
I think it's gonna be our dealio I have no idea what was supposed to be for me
maybe the veal or collab actually where we get to look at pretty girl sorry I
just had to look at the news yes it's actually a bit weird a pretty harsh yes
but I made an interesting discovery that I need to talk to your
colleague Harrison yes I was just chatting I set up a conference colleague
that would be great a lot of reading give me a moment
honestly I was like oh let's play this game wait a minute I need to read
oh lord
you're gonna be one more time starting at something get and put in that ep
mouth of yours I am is that a promise
oh and then we're gonna go back to this one
got a face that we're known wait it's like huh you take me what Nina mentioned
the cops are wiretapping her calls why not chat I think the call is much more
appropriate for legal councils raises less arbors and chats might be logged
we're just the average couple seeking advice right couple we need to do this
don't speak too openly don't mention wiretaps okay
I'm like this alright right group call
she's not tired anymore she's something else
hey Yosef seems like this is working hello I'm Harrison I presume yes and
you're the law guy he's a good girl let's meet
I just read about your group I guess this isn't exactly brightening things up
for you you could say that the rules here has big
faith in your skills Yosef here to elaborate on what you
found out yes okay so you all know the safety
yes yeah all in all it's an aggregation of paragraphs to get people
behind bars is much more easily and prior in lives as necessary
no they use it as a sorry excuse for spying on people all the time
intimidating them yes I understand what's particularly dangerous about it for
you is that individuals might be prosecuted by mere indication of
threats to the nation in specific situations it will be
more than enough to point at a word you said in a rage to consider
you dangerous that's enough to hold you in for some time
but what's even more problematic for you is the so-called
a transivity of indication the what you all form a group an activist group this
links you to one another now if there was sufficient
indication that say Abraham created thought to commit crimes
or even acts of terrorism well they have grounds to arrest you all
but we didn't do anything how is this just this is so
freaking outrageous they'll twist and turn their so-called evidence until they
get what they need you will need to be very very careful from no one
we can do something about this right we need explicit evidence showing
Abraham created this group to be peaceful prove it beyond any doubt
this is why I need to ask you about Abraham to find out his original
intentions well ask away the two of us were friends for a
while but I never got the feeling he told me a lot about what was going on in
his life he was reclusive indeed that's what he was like
except when he was around thought how was thought formed he found out about me
by discovering my blog said he wanted to start a debate club
I said fine we had a couple of lame meetings nothing much happened
a debate club then that would be good that could
hardly be regarded as a terrorist asset uh yes but Abe was obsessed with getting
his message out make people aware what the government was doing
right that's kind of a given right anti-government and you go
then we went with so it was Nina why and we know why and we know why don't we
he wanted to get out of the contract of illness but the government said no
so as we said Nina oh god stop stop telling me everything Jesus
right Nina thought of the protest so it was miss
November the mall yeah during the studies I met Abraham online by chance
he motivated me to take his course
hold on more vigilio right then jules took over with the planning for the two
protests okay you false intention the bad planning causes you
Nina me each and every one of us is guilty of deviating from the intention
jules you don't know what you're talking about it was Nina she neglected
Nina was pretty violent I'm gonna be honest like I kind of feel like Nina was
the violent one cause I think it was that one
sorry but Nina literally reached for a
a pew pew I'm not sure if I'm willing to believe this is really contradictory
to what Abraham wanted if so wait didn't he not bomb him on purpose
no he said they went too far if so why are we doing the same
okay he's gone we don't know where and we don't know how to reach him
sadly oh well I will need to get back to writing some emails
of course I understand jesus I'll get back to you I suppose it was going to
benefit you too well because Sandra is removed from custody yes goodbye
yes thanks don't mention it and use your quit well the lawyer wasn't too helpful
come on give a rest this is a complicated situation yes so what's
nice I suggest we meet somewhere in town
the old meeting place
oh and jules the old meeting place on jules what the band location
must be the band location something important to them shame they didn't say
but resting item is out of the question we don't have enough evidence
right give me the band because that's clearly a band thing where's the band
the targets I know for a fact it'll be one of the locations here
yikes come on it has to be a location here I don't believe it otherwise
give us an address don't be shy okay maybe be a little bit shy hold on I'm
being dumb I'm going the wrong way freedom is unfree
your thoughts are free
oh there's like tons of more comments I hope you guys get what you deserve
we want you out mfers
ooh the location they used to hook up at his trailer
oh my god this is giving me like nothing right he said he was gonna send more
emails right
is there more emails nope
what if you put it in the bin for me to look at why yes of course make it super
easy for me african to say there's one thing here
I'll just shove it in because it's cluttering it says I can interact with
it go
okay we don't really care but it's that we better go
so strange financial troubles and large donations don't go hand in hand
right what did I miss in the dialogue
he got fired that's not really a big deal is it is it might oh maybe it is
because I literally have no other leads whatsoever
um I literally have no other lead I'm gonna just start spamming stuff in
the intimate moment
am I supposed to where is that located intimate moment
intimate moment
must be between them way back down here
yeah no idea okay all of us are looking at each other right now
and a room of me and refling all of us are looking at each other for an answer
right why does this keep saying it's blue
whatever is blue I'm ignoring it because we keep saying I can interact with
something when I can't
okay no one cares literally no one cares
how
what did I miss
okay that's fine jose is a planner we figured that out
what was their favorite places to go to I don't know but I can't like pull it up
or find it to show that Harrison has been involved
but since we know that uh plan Nina planned the first
there's now leaves no room for him did we make a mistake
yeah I might not let them make a mistake Mr. Goldfield seems quite the
charmer look all these people gathered around them
oh we got something here
campus life juuuuusy
Charles had a new portrait so I got a notebook for my studying
oh it's literally got your computer code on the back of it
that's hilarious thanks you please do more of that again that made it
that made it so easy more of this please okay
russon's own system trash what are you hiding greetings from cool past
Orwell has lost connection to the main server
uh
the connection's been re-established
do you receive my message ah there we go I just had a strange kind of connection
problem it was like the mainframe banished
still got some data loss between the server in here seems like it's slowly
going back to norm again we had a joker who thought he could
intrude our database info6 said they had averted the attack
huh I'm not sure how much I believe that the attack was
averted still always don't bother the law
I don't I just got an achievement but I don't know what just said
hold on I've missed something
I've can I've conducted a talk with the members of thought of course they
claim to be neither involved in the bombing nor being contact with
Abraham thought was formed as a debate club then became
activists there is this juliet counting he seems rather harmless but this
might be a fanatic talking them gave me an impression he is thoughts leader
if you can call him that he openly spoke out against the government
he clearly seems to be a fanatic observe him remember our agreement
hmm
what was that one still again your course
akim has family in germany
hello loiter faske it's a little bit good yeah
good bitter
spelen open mine and or welly and I'm just making up german by the way this
isn't real german I'm speaking uber hacks are over we got hacks we've
been born what's that horror game where like the
thing can jump out at you
um
about a project called demiurge
it's so over it's dimmer hmm I feel like I've heard that name before but
I don't mean from Greek mythology hmm
which is demiurge you need demiurgers but you know that's what I just looked on
right have I checked it
status he's just chillaxing relaxing all cool
meet some people outside of the school
and a couple of guys who were up to no good
started making trouble in the neighborhood
why are they
just checking out the office
behold
hmm I'm getting stuck in this game I don't remember being stuck before
hmm is there anything red no just as the notebook one right
block this because this is useless she's determined
okay that doesn't help me help me
destroyer of the creator creations destroyer of the high table
I wouldn't mind
oh no I'm like proper locked out there's nothing giving me a hint here
I'm looking for a symbol on the right side that indicates that there's
something more
the people
the five great nice uh the five great pillars of the nation
really that's delacroix remember her name being mentioned
like the keepers of the mission
huh how do I participate
the demiurges and the usurper maybe try reviewing the timeline again
I think you can do it
nope right initiate I don't know nothing about you bro
what am I supposed to do I wasn't paying attention please
stop this madness he was quite reclusive I mean
I'm not really gonna do anything about
there's something
anything here there's just more comments of everyone
absolutely hating on them
anything American nope
the thoughts are free I can't believe I'm actually stuck in a point-and-click
game are you joking a point-and-click game is too much for me
a fucking point-and-click is really called objective
faint hints about the whereabouts of Abraham
faint hints on the whereabouts of big eve
uh
where would you be big Abraham
Abraham Abraham big Abraham
Abraham is anyone emailing big Abraham
I don't know okay some old school point got apparently had to find the pics they'll
miss it in your games over 10 hours let's stop what the fuck
Juliet's timeline university maybe something new on the university
he's gone I don't know where he is but he's gone
maybe there's a new student that I can investigate maybe by putting the
things that you thought you would make with animal I think I'm gonna have to
right go back I take it back undisable it whatever it was
I'm sure this is really uh really part of the plot let me get a thought up
unlock like three things
okay about I'm about to get told off right website gallery right let's just
call him
we're not around here yeah sure enable oh my god he's gay
oh I've cracked the case boys he was homosexual
daily this makes me question we're supposed to know this whether we're
allowed to okay like I'm just trying to find the
answer okay uh I'm about to get spanked for
uh obviously he's a pug that is the true answer he's a pug
that's not the dog we're looking for jesus they start taking things seriously
well maybe if you gave me the answer because what am I supposed to do
the omnipresent interwebs is where you live obviously
we're getting desperate I don't know what I'm supposed to do are you squidding me
right now michi chunky bird thank you for
extending your membership I don't know what I'm to say it thank you for
membership for one month time for bird to sleep good night strong good night
everyone I wouldn't be joining you very shortly in bed because I cannot figure
this out
start a war on the government okay that's fine
what is our will okay he's aware of our will I'm sure that leads to
great things like yes of course oh look at everything popping up in opening
yay because I know what I'm doing right that's all the conversations checked
that is just nothing I had to start repairing my notebook
sure oh you're so determined we love you being
determined shadow is your money game the dog is behind everything
right I'm not right it must be her freaking computer
what am I missing I'm missing something obvious
you just started here this month
come on the photo I got got me hacked
come on I can make it come on let me finish the chapter before I go
yes yes yes oh my god you're so german hallo leiterbacket
oh wait abrahams in germany oops
season germany oh thank you shone thank you shone
bitter bitter okay okay bitter bitter
why that baby's so freaked out getting a photo seems
this is a child yes he has a wane oh my god gunter
gunter argons oh my god gunter
it's legitimate to change your name when immigrating very yet very few do it this
is what he does I forgot his actual birthday is then
oh my god oh my god so he is married oh my god I
submitted that he's not married I'm pretty sure oopsie
it was an innocent mistake okay it was an innocent
mistake attacking or will work how dare you initiate you're so stinky
look on your thought web server this guy was behind the breakdown
take a look on your thought web server handle with care was that mean
this
huh he's fake to his own death gunter what have you done
this is not good dubis nice dot nine dubis
newt dot oh again was me on oh sorry oh i'm going to hit the fact that we can
only look at points of date without knowing the full story the truth is
there but we don't see it damn it screw it screw or will I need to think look at
the facts again just watch for a while and let's think that gimley
just watch for a while and let me know if anything new happens okay
oh so the report came from abraham's address came in it was completely
abandoned no furniture left nothing which is no longer
she's literally screaming on the other side of the door
oh my bro be better calm down i bet you are
gunter is undertage
oh
uh oh
they know
oh
benjamin here's a government agent oh wait that's who i'm talking to big benny
uh they know about you benny boy
i am not friends with why am i where did that come from i'll grant you to add more if there's
anything i want to know i need to know
no
has a pregnant fiance benjamin here's a government agent
in the project he called or will i mean that's true
i mean here's a picture of you if you want oh he's using the against no
oh or using it against him no no no
oh wait are we about to take down our own agent
i'm an idea should i not be doing this right now you're engaged to your wife
how is this possible this cannot be happening i need to go home now
yeah you need to go home to your
wait are we are we actually accidentally helping i think we're helping then the
you know you are showing him how wait i thought he said he wanted to am i being dumb
i'm an idiot i think i'm not very smart i apologize
i think i'm completely messed up this game um
oopsie he wants he wants to know what they know and the answer is everything
but you already know where he lives you're snitching on your own co-workers
oops like it was an accident i didn't mean it
i'll put that fake picture of him perishing up because why not
wait so if he's away you know driving home to work
take a look on your web server handle the care
oh wait it's the end of the day
it's the end of the day day four
oh but we've only got one more episode to go i'm pretty sure we might as well there
no don you did it oh his identity was personal information was exposed
who did that oh no who did that benjamin oh dear i didn't understand my actions
okay we're on the can someone look up of episode five's the last one i think there's
only five chapters to this game oh good morning invest dear justice i was an accident okay it's
all the pugs fall i don't know what i was doing good morning investigator since you have the most
powerful investigation to let your disposal i suspect you already know who i am not really
you on the other hand have been mediocre so far you could not save them all but you could
you at least got the prime suspect you will do better i will be your new advisor in this case
this has become far too important to leave the case with to an advisor with an exposed identity
same as well but no longer fit to work on orwell moving forward we will not speak about him again
as far as your concern he never existed on you with yesterday's reveal of orwell sympathizers
for this group have taken to the streets we need to show all of the nation orwell is keeping them
safe we won't allow some fools to trample on everything we chew we must get rid of the imposter
pretending to be abraham find out who did it and where they are hiding
the game orwell has a total of two seasons keeping an eye on you the first season has five okay so
we are in the last one where the headlines house of exposed government employee vandalize
i hope he's alive are you squinting me right now
slice safer thank you for supporting me for a month please don't snitch on us to the high
table we'll do anything yeah you'll do anything i bet you will i say i bet you will i'll make you
do anything who did that his private oh my god his private address was exposed oh no
that's time
anti orwell protesters gather at the freedom memorial oh no wait a minute are we taking
down the surveillance i might have accidentally exposed him but i'm kind of getting what i want
negotiations renewed really i don't think anyone cares about you're bluffing
yeah members of thought my dear friends as you've all experienced today we're already besieged
by the government they have denounced us called us terrorists and turned the public against us
this will stop their day is about to come to an end i have a plan but for this to work we must
meet like we did the old ways when we had our meetings and cafe chestnut oh no that's actually in
the book the chestnut cafes in the book we will have a conference called 4 p.m because i'm well aware
the meeting in person won't work you will you need not fear surveillance always been taken
careful care of how am i supposed to report that or do i want them to like i kind of want them to
survive though um kind of want them to i mean this is the only lead i have so sure you didn't
just showed him what had been exposed and that was important a gathering we know abraham
is passed away someone must be imperative this is clearest crystal we must act swiftly and
collect as much evidence as possible for gathering commences this is certainly no good as you know
processing data chunks and it's time i would say we have rough time for roughly 20
oh no
okay you must think i'm sure first you don't want to tell me we've won wait up i want to take them down
i want to take them down though wait had to hold on
i had to take them down they'll not need to like
the 10 command no that's rosentick
oh my god gimme is about to do my button people her
her
pug profile picture was a throw you can't upload pug profile pictures anymore yeah
i want to take them down like i'm that's who i'm talking to
hmm i don't think maybe i need to like throw some stuff out anything
okay okay we'll just do ghost them i saw you yesterday that's confirmation
they said don't fear the upload though so doesn't even matter what i do related document found
this is where harrison did his thought we're probably thinking we won't be able to track him
down we will track him down i've gone through the information we have on the remaining suspects
regarding the impersonation of abraham we have received information from a reliable source that
odonal is probably the leader of thought odonal predicted the bomb but this alone makes him suss
we have no idea why odonal hid the post on the thought blog on his timeline we are yet to
clarify why odonal would frequent a bomb a drugstore often perhaps for the materials
why would odonal have two health insurances it's apparent that harrison odonal might as well
i don't think it's him he is probably the one impersonating him i want you to prove this and
lock him away for good i don't think it's him i can be honest with you chief lobby
hi score loading host meet your host oh is that her
no
is that him
him
former admin
huh
what's on your pc system browser
benjamin costigan
and
who's big benji
this confirmant is behind the exposure we knew that already oh sorry
who's big benjamin that's any can
we's gotta where's my phone okay we'll grab it something
i think i already have it where are you why did you leave apes our plan was to
hate something until we know the public enemy number one and two yeah that was before i found
out what you did what did he do you expose the government employee take a closer look at what
happened thereafter is for now was that necessary julia are you joking your life's in danger and
all you can think about is a government employee so look at we have developed falling if they
prosecute us now there'll be public outcry this tiny crowd with their banners won't stop a thing
we'll be gone forever once again this is why i had to leave did you get abraham's email yeah that was
crazy i know all of a sudden he's back and he has a plan i can't believe it he where was he the
whole time will you attend the gathering what the fuck is the gathering
one tape faster hand Jesus don't hate away it's hating somewhere where she has not stayed in
the last couple of course he must attend i will hide away in someplace i'll call
in from my notebook you should do the same they might check there first well the
my damn phone is gone just like you disappeared this morning you haven't seen it by chance
jesus can you not take care of your stuff no i haven't seen your phone who's got the phone then
ben was the guy you were just talking to oh dumb ass eat oh fuck it try to crack
track it down but it doesn't seem to sing that probably out barry yeah whatever i'll just go
without it until the gathering yeah until the gathering whoa what's this i'm sorry for him
jonathan uh three frank wait why is that red though oh i've got access to his emails now from
his pov okay that's just i didn't have access to them before because i suck right we already know
his mobile browser history oh is that all no personal your life trust invoice
i had special health insurance covering family members
dixon i just want to thank for your support in the ball post
i mean how many nicknames has she got i love you rebel punk god okay
as you may have not heard i've been affiliated group called clotting path i thought i might
as well bow that right on your face before some dataminer does include yeah let them claim
shit if they love worthless once upon a time there's a death punk who thought to build an
activist group but failed awfully the moral of the story is your activism isn't worth shiz
because peeps just don't care as you may or may not have heard the the big bunch of
at least now you know don't say you haven't been warned okay yeah so he was a freaking
rebel the entire time wait so then what's so important on your browser the phone number
i think we already have it do we not
oh we can see his phone
so that's his house
oh i don't know if i can track it that well hold on a minute
yeah i'm really sorry for enjoying the best game because i'm doing it for like rates
wait actually is him no two cent
is it actually him
whoa it's actually him
there's this little lady new portrait
is it actually him
there's jules
he did happy birthday have a good one
what he did it unless the other guy has his phone
oh my god
rates mail as abraham what no this camera
i don't know if his house and we're done after it well done make sure to have all the relevant
locations so we can make another red
that's his house i don't know what one is
is that just another mall i don't know
initiate knock knock huh who are you names initiate
oh you're the hacker guy right
my dinner so you had the thought why you've been following us around why what do you want
what i want i want to know what happened to dots these bomba have been ringing in my head
and i just don't know was this thoughts work was it a government setup
listen i don't know either i'm sorry but shed is majorly going down the drain right now
if you can help us do it please i fear my hope got you where you are right now
i just assumed that's what he sounds like you'll help the docs
you don't talk so openly or do you forget what's going on right sorry can you do that again
what you did no
they're going to track me down for sure barely got out the last time
i don't know why i'm starting to sound Swedish i need more intel
the first thing i don't see that way damn so what are you doing oh you don't know yet
Abraham Goldfields who founded thought sent us a message
thought should gather him once more what Abe is back yeah when he said he has a plan you know him
kind of we're from coincidence
yeah he's the one who gave Harrison your man's information look look if you know Abraham
why don't you attend this gathering as well it's going down four p.m the conference come
give me your number and i'll find you no thanks but no thanks sounds like a trap to me
you shouldn't attend either i'm pretty positive it's not the email sounded authentic
but have it your way i will good luck with this gathering
i like the real thing initiate equals benjamin
big benny good luck with your findings i don't know what's going on there you're gonna need it
Harrison is pretending to be Abe he's getting them all together for a reason
gonna nuke him in the stratosphere what a strange so that just needs to you know guess
which one i know it's not his hoose i don't know and i've got a clue i'm just shoving them all down
they're offline offline
i'll just keep submitting them wouldn't that imply he docks himself
oh good thing
okay that's
oh we've got a hit on something
initiate i need to apologize for my excitement i have been working on a plan and hiding today
today i need to call upon your help to make it happen i'm aware of your capability you need to
stop trying to tear down walls and stitch shifting to running through open doors here's
where to find one 4 p.m which is this by the way has worked out a plan involving initiate initiate
in contact with him but we already have access to gunters phone if you even want to call it that
sorry i'm too small brain for this honestly high scores
is the high score like gonna be the honeypot
hosts
oh my god rattlesnake it's you it's not
ip address in a port
is it you wicked witch no
former admin really isn't that much of a
thing to go off of
right gimme his phone
you're sending more mail aren't you
why is it only showing me one oh no you're sending
are they gonna get away if i fuck this i think they are new portrait new portrait
is he doing it because of what big farmer did to his mall
honestly i'd be so done for the plot if that was it
and there's four endings i have no idea how to get them i have no idea how to get them to
jose we already have your number
former admin is not a lead please stop offering me it
at the last location i mean we know it's wrong but i guess
she's gonna talk to me half her time's up stay diligent
what the heck we don't need contacts gallery mohen skychat not right so the phone isn't
taking me anywhere where's his desktop
no what why desktop is not a phone desk are you joking me right now
this desktop is there something in here
Harrison's timeline metamorphis
metamorphis fashe
why does it suck so bad at this game i don't remember it being this hard
oh we're just gonna play the tinfoil hat game i'm like bro i'm having a stroke trying to figure
anything out right we'll just do that wrong profile but whatever we'll just do a little
a little pug
so they are going to try and attack orva once again fine let them come
finishy uh we're heading sure just i think we're gonna have to throw this one because i don't
know what the earth i'm doing the initiates and you and you must reveal this true identity
this might shed some light on what it's mobs are
you and me we're done
we're damn phone is gone don't hate me then i'm lost right now
sure we'll just stick on juliet i think you're doing fine from why i genuinely don't know what
the game's asking me to do right now i useful hint if you encounter any hints to hide out
be sure to validate them by checking where they've stayed for me right now do that at all mama be
like i'll do shorter easy streams while my dad is here also mama four hours deep into a confusing
conspiracy oh literally i can't help but i thought this was gonna take like three hours i'm so confused
right what's the is rebank again that's fine behold
well he's in trouble now isn't he i think they all are
are
this thing i'm doing something terribly wrong
i'm you this game so i think you're doing all right thank you briefly i think i'm just gonna
have to spam them stuff right he's lost his phone oh no he's lost wait he's lost his phone
wait a minute abraham can't be texting from his thing if he's lost his damn phone
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it if he's lost his wait kassandra
we haven't seen you in a while
you must have had a hand in this for sure well maybe i did
thank you thank you thank you wait i'm going to pick you up you sure you don't have to work
work can't wait what the heck happened to you is this the same joseph it's a long story i will tell
you on our way out i'm so looking forward to seeing you again gonna be there in about 20 minutes
season yeah can't be soon enough right so she's reunite a couple apparently how did we reunite
a couple what because i failed to indict her there's the horse keeps coming up i don't see
how him being a former freaking admin is relevant but i'm it just keeps telling me do it's a fine
horse you're what you win you win game i'm submit information that's wasting my shows
founder and boss of the bunch
more than 2048 computing citizens
it's
lobby high scores
one of these is an ip address oh well that number is clearly something but i've not found what it is
let's have one comment about ghost and like and it's useless it must be something on the computer
or a check it says the picture of his mum is that why he's taken down big pharma
right okay that was a waste but it's okay contacts who
do
update the number to jules
check cassie's stuff now that her machine is alive
i don't have it oh i don't have a cassie's machine
huh
how would i obtain it that number i can
scoop her phone from contacts give me give me cassie's phone
then i can go through her phone right
yeah
i already had access to her phone whips i don't have her like the id number of the phone though
what a confusing game oh my goodness i don't like popego
i mean i'm not sure that's gonna prove anything about
a band is it back on the band
we're putting the band back together bad ending um i'm getting the bad end i'm
getting the failed ending where i had nothing because i don't know what we've been
10 top blood cat pictures just for the last few honestly i might
this get in touch the tank commander
on that website that shows the owner
because it had that lady on it
not our family the other one it was like
people her she's in it you you this you it's something to do with her it has to be
but literally nothing is getting like highly either opened or
anything i'm just getting roll let's say i can old like add old numbers i've submitted the location
i've already submitted so i don't i think i just submit any old pitch now you know that
oh no he's not oh sorry mommy i'm no coming home tonight sorry oh that's okay bad one
i'm coming home she's actually a government official yeah okay well we've got two more
let's just submit whatever it does not matter at this point i don't know what i'm doing
and maybe it'll make more sense to make if we have like another attempt
but right now my brain it's almost 4 p.m almost like to have one more time for an upload make
sure it counts oh i'll make sure an upload counts all right um how about we do
is there even anything
there's not one thing okay it must be in this pc that can submit or
there let's do this most useless piece of information like a puzzle get you and me
we're done yeah very important
i am not particularly interested in the love life of a terrorist
it's 4 p.m i'm getting intervention teams ready to check all the locations
now to wait to see what happens uh what's going on
we they hacked them
oh no what happens if they delete the whole system oh no
i love sniffing the thoughts are free
oh yay pokechan it's the pug let's go puggy wuggy
hi mrsly you lurking in the shadows
oh we've got a group call going
hello is this working anybody here well i am
harry i didn't know if you would still be around
barely got here in time cassie you've been released yeah thanks to jossie i don't know
what magic trick he pulled off but it worked jossie this is great i am not quite sure what
i'm doing here but i am here as well joseph great oh joseph joseph great you're there holy crap
what is this who are you a fool who is baffled by the madness he just witnessed otherwise initiate
well i'm glad you decided to join us that's completely unintended what do you mean you're
in the call aren't you yeah i'm also in orwell in orwell aib sent me an ip address to get into
orwell it makes hacking the damn thing incredibly easy you did what and that worked like a charm
i now kind of control the damn thing it's really really worrying come again you have orwell on a
freaking leash great how does that worry you my control is limited and the government will get
the control back at some point but this isn't my primary concern what makes me nervous is why
would abraham have such extensive knowledge of orwell this whole thing reeks of an enormous trap
abled betray us no he wouldn't but you're right something very strange as a foot we should get
out right now and this is the point where it gets even worse i had a quick look at his file
you would not believe what it says he's dead abraham is dead yeah he died quite some time ago
what that's impossible i thought that when we he first disappeared but i put it to the back
of my mind what became of him dead no abraham how he was very sick answer oh so that was real
oh you old fool we couldn't tell us he gave nina the orders for the bomba after his demise
this means this means someone has been setting her up real bad and not only
her all of us who the f would do such a thing i'm not getting info on who or why
what a pity but it does prove my point wait what do you mean jules it was me i set you up what
jules you wait a sec i can't believe where this is going are you for real right now are you
are you telling me you told nina to place those bombas i did i'm not proud of it but i had to be
it had to be done what the heck why you and nina youtube ruined everything for abraham
and for thought so you decided that leaving me wasn't enough for revenge you had to bomb innocent
people and blame it on thought it was necessary only when things are at their darkest will people
listen take note and actually enact change he knew that i know it was extreme extreme extremist
murder i know believe me i know you are the reason i was in custody how could you do that to me
thought needed to be destroyed that was the whole point instead of seeking me out and
labelled you all target persons and investigated you all screwed up your lives people need to see
how messed up orwell is it's not protection it's invasive and manipulation doom for everyone
note if no one is innocent everyone is a suspect abe wanted to make the world stand up against
orwell he knew how dangerous project word that's why he worked on it he did what he worked on it
this confirms what i feared but i didn't want to believe it if so he could have gone to the
media and taken it all public couldn't he he was afraid he thought nothing would ever change
if he did can you blame him he told me everything and told only me damn oh funny i just realized
you're actually much better yet much worse activists than nina or me could have ever been
that's admirable in a strange mess up way you're nothing but a biatch julia a killer a liar
cassie i oh just shut up shut up just shut up shut up this is madness julia first cassie then
you pulled me into this all those people who suffered at your hand i still don't get it why draw
all of this attention on thought you didn't convince anyone by your actions why this
gathering why let me hack orwell i needed to convince just one person have faulty orwell is
cause again the guy harry leaked information about was the man on the inside only an advisor
the person who was really been spying on you still around the person who actually went through
your stuff passed on the day of the one listening right now the investigator that's me that's right
i'm talking to you i knew you had to be around where everyone would come together you had to
be listening initiate was just a win for a chance to make sure you'd not immediately go up against
those investigator i have a question for you now that you saw orwell firsthand do you really think
that the system will help anyone do you think the government would not spy on you as well
did you think you were outside the system think again they evaluate even you even you
that he saw the madness they observe even you the investigators but we can stop it you can
remember you became recruited for being outside of the system outside the nation what if we show
people what they store about you that even you are not outside this as we're about to get docs
because it's one of those meta games that show your ip address all you need to do investigators
upload the data they have on you incriminating yourself this is so mind-bogglingly stupid
jewels why would the investigator the government will come after that's exactly the point the
evaluation is supposed to be a safety net so that no one misuses orwell active acting on
evidence is mandatory if the investigator criminates himself they'll be forced to prosecute them and
reveal this evidence that the investigators are actually being spied on this is absolutely mad i
do not see this working i would love to offer an alternative investigator it just so happens that
a certain catherine dilla qua is in these files too i say we make use of the fact we have control
on over orwell let's use as a weapon and turn it against the government there's all there's
something dirty to be found about her for sure let's act on that now we're talking no hurting won't
help much she's just gonna get replaced this isn't the right way like i said jules just shut it nobody's
interested in what you have to say but how can we trust this investigation what what the heck
how did they find harrison what's going on oh no seems he just fell prey to the surveillance
system oh shit we need to act fast i ratted him him out let me all show you what i can see right
now here streams up here's kassandra's file well this feels like a slap in my face they have been
collecting all of this they got me flagged potentially dangerous it was this investigator oh
don't be mad hen no i can't trust that person i'm out use of your turn my turn
hmm oh no what's funny about your file it says here you were offered a release of kassandra
for info on thought and you agreed especially given the fact what just happened to harrison
damn yes i did i got the offer and i reported harrison i had to kassandra would not have been
released otherwise oh it's all falling apart i can't believe this this is horrible but then again
you did it for me i don't know what to think merde kass i'm sorry for harry i can't take this
anymore leave me out of all of this oh she's gone kassie wait you've got to do this without me i'm
sorry user quit well this is just great see how we've messed up all this is is exactly what we
need to show the people show them how we've been affected get them to fight with us i shall speak
on behalf of nina then nina's popped her clogs i only realize now i might have been my fault nina
got investigated in the first place oops but it's all clear the investigator is responsible for hunting
her down like this look it was i didn't they chased her to death oh they caused her death no doubt
perhaps investigator didn't know any better and we know nina was gilly it does not strengthen my
trust though but then the investigator arrested harrison no no we cannot trust such a person
meaning the final verdict is oh is he out not a single vote to trust the investigator oh
i'm getting sniped are we finally gonna do this my way it's down to the two of us it seems well
my plan to gather support for you failed investigator but if you still want to fulfill my plan go on
and give delacrox hell you will find something dirty investigators time to make up your mind
you can tear down the entire system just complete my plan please i will turn delacrox into a target
person i think i can easily activate access to a pc for you as well what
hoisin it's hacramen when abraham stopped his work for rosentech and the government he cloned
all information he had and hid it in the office he told me and i maintained that the system is
programmed to boot itself again in a couple of minutes you'll have access to everything you just
need to find the uid of the device i cannot tell you here now that orwell isn't tracking data
junk i feel understanding if you judge and incriminate me for what i've done i think i deserve it
it's up to you now investigator do the right thing right how do we destroy it finally i thought the
disturbance would never end the back end engineer said we've had an unwanted guess we already know
it was thought it's about time we undo them we must be strong we must show these people for what
they are the nation's safety depends on it finally waiting to incriminate them together as group all
we need is a hint that abraham intended this group to carry out acts we could trace the attacks back
to a remote pc it will now manually unlock the pc for you
destroy delacrox
can we replay this section i think the good ending is doing what juliet says okay it's in a
computer she said no she said it was in someone else's computer
are you going anti-government yeah how did i do juliet's thing she said it would unlock a computer
hers it's an ebes computer
i don't have ebes computer meanwhile it's an ebes computer how do i find
it's a various ending right so i need to find ebes computer from her notes
you all got any bunches of letters and numbers in here didn't she say go to the rosen website
okay okay rosen rosen r4 rosen
we've got numbers we've got numbers but welcome page
5.106224 uh uh-huh and attain commandments
somewhere on the website somewhere on the website the six commandments synchronize over
do not waste your clients on time by bonding with communication via email it's almost always
more efficient to get directly in touch with one another if you get this is why we have no email
addresses what are you going to call us directly new portrait
10 commandments
you can do better no matter what you can do you can never give up
embrace the client we think clients move there this is like actually
you need to call juliet's phone
uh oh juliet are you there is there any juliet's
they call juliet's phone
okay all like her actual phone like this i don't have her phone like that way
i've her phone this way but her number was on the website
i'm clicking i'm clicking so hard right now
okay i already have it so why is it on my phone click harder
uh um
juliet text mail mail history cut your mail book i have your number
click me
you're a mother f***ing phone number
did we softlock ourselves to one ending wait you can do that
click click click click have i softlocked myself i have access to initiative in kathryn
if you destroy you end a political career if you leak your own data it will cause
an enshrash of our nation the problem is i don't know how to do it i think i might have
locked myself out from via pure gameplay because they're saying get juliet's number but we already
own it on the website data submitted work phone
i can't interact with any of them
isn't there a second number of juliet's and harrison's phone
i swear if you've got that kind of brain
you
there's talk fun time
we already knew good kick and iron as well we are doing africans victor
juliet victor here oh hey victor i just talked to maria why are you not at work oh i sent a
seeking off the leading i don't know the river no you did not you were here the entire weekend
that's what the tracker says but no one authorized you to do so now that you are meant to be here you
are not also what is this under your account how do i get into it can i just add it i don't want her
to see it but i need i need to be able to get into it i don't want the crocs to see it but i need in
okay there we go we're in
okay those are devices that's fine contacts anything that stands out not really
what are your chats about come on tell me where the tell me where the bomber are
oh
wasn't there a clickable number in contacts
it's just kassandra's one
okay
dm's to her but kassandra kassandra
she used to shut up i made the right one i wonder right now how do you talk to me do you
talk to me i mean there was a number for eve it was aives wait she'll come out
how am i going past this is it not highly in it anymore is it giving me a wee challenge
i never saw it highly it does i have to fly past that
go what do you expect to happen on this floor just let me in okay let me in open the door
how was the floor
okay now we have aives number i surely know what to do with such a
why is kassandra's highland
we're talking about a day there's a lot gets on a bus every day to suggest freedom plaza
route
juliet is the mastermind behind it juliet that's no
i still
that's just gonna it was possibly coerced into being by juliet
incredible
incredible these people use smiley faces way too much right i don't want to go into her
i have a phone number we have made progress
harris got charged oh yo multiple incidents of murder
found a lone in orchid drive working on his laptop which was connected to a public
wi-fi hotspot when the suspect noticed our arrival he attempted to flee but was quickly
cornered by officers he complied and offered no resistance
hmm these people i don't know what you're talking about smile cheeky new profile picture
right i've been given aives number so is there like
so here's the control if ape is dead then a man will just talk to him
i'm losing it i'm losing it i think it's happening
i think you guys are literally gonna have to tell me each piece of information because i have no idea
can we go back to the phone to see what juliet said hey jules what's up he
a bit swamped it's friday hangout no romantic dinner the haunted house
but go so she coerced her to basically go on the bus so she could get blamed
however thanks oh hey good meet and greet
juliet where are your mat work it's so beautiful that you could come out don't miss it he worked
i mean it's not really a secret
i have no clue either tyfus games are juliet being at work all weekend against company
policies seems important you're not supposed to follow abraham he said we're wasting precious time
i'm sorry my bad chief my bad chief
oh
demurge i command you to no longer dig around abraham's path i could easily turn you into
a target person for disobeying me you would not want that would you what what is strange though
is that parenting requested material in this demurge it doesn't matter focus on undoing thought
as a whole uh i abraham developed this codex for a project named demurge which has been renamed
orwell and i have proof of everything we've got his pc oh so now you know it yes i hired him for
orwell this is his doing it was me who wanted him on the project in the first place to get
things right with orwell to follow ethical standards only very few people knew here knew that and i wanted
to make sure it stayed that way our most ferocious enemy worked for us a person i choose now you
know all discovered by the very tool it was all about the irony is not lost on me but while you
chose to do i warned you this will have consequences i've uncovered the truth riefling no
wait a minute
what why are we floating off we're having like a little fight over here honestly right we can
finally get a cockroach from what you've told me you're more planned to bomb bomba and incite
nina to do it on a certain date okay i don't really want to if we're trying to take down
papa papa is that you isn't it don't ask i find it to me quite well you hit your chase as well but
so manage abraham gold is this who you are just do it for her we're looking good enough for we're
going away we're seeing sayonara literally why am i way over here so she's put me in the system
i don't understand why you never turn to the press
i was urged by to destroy his pc urged juliet to destroy his work
okay i don't want to submit anything yet until it's like time to submit if that makes sense
i'm getting i'm getting a little nervous i'm getting shaky because uh we're all of a sudden on this
map the development says severe problems
stairs of the profile picture and how security
person of interest uh targeted persons appear to make things even worse interest third human
element is being evaluated to oversee the call evaluation so wait why is that the wrong profile
it's me i'm being evaluated
reefing no you need to be careful you will surely understand human elements are prone to me so
we had to do this oh it's over for you
flagged sea watergate is dangerous believes that oh my god wait is this gonna conflict no
no okay i'm doxing myself in order to
oh my god i know this might upset that we tracked your progress but we need to feel safe
we could not just deliver random people to operate it without a backup i mean we need
something in place in the event okay i'm doing it rating trustworthy
hey what are you doing self-incrimination to what end
sloppy a third bomb sloppy you can't call me sloppy stop that once or you will have to prosecute
you uh i mean i guess that one's more important i need to do in order
oh
government cancels or will oh government announces immediate termination of or will
oh we took it down no evidence against karrington karrington is deceived
thought welcomes investigator oh reefing you did it
reefing you did it
oh i'm broke as hell though
it's like we're looping the background sounds
possibly trying to evade prosecution what continues
so
big brother all well
i'm still on we're a traitor to the nation and or will
it will have a sequel i didn't know that
oh so did i do the right
well i don't know if we can replay that ending section the tin foil complaints
and karrington gets away when we're there you betrayed the nation will not be in the nation
there's also an ending where you put delacrop so can i quickly do that version
now let's hide in the embassy of another country what one will we pick well i'll pick the american
embassy will americans be nice to me smile i have no idea if they'd be nice to me
gg i'm gonna see if i can replay the other version
gg snowton approves honestly like i'm wearing this tin foil dot jpeg for no reason i ain't a png
we hate transparency unless i was clearly because of the freaking thing
although i got an eyelash in my bow ow i'm ripping the eyelash
i asked juliana stasher how you doing in the news it's for whistleblowers bro
whistleblower the concept of whistleblowers just absolutely destroys my mind
and she's like oh this person told the truth about the oh sweet
man made horrors beyond my comprehension being brought to lay oh no he's in trouble
okay just call me a whistle yeah you would refling you would can't be whistleblowers
no i can't really skip this nothing's happening
so i say thank you for the uh the tip tiny spanish mommy will be like i'll do short streams
i think i might have forgotten to say your name for the tip but thank you thank you i'm i'm a small
brain for juliana he didn't even leak anything he just owns the platform i need my whistleblower
actually that's for the members they all start up in two weeks by the way please do not be
be not afraid children for it all starts up in two weeks she broke out the camp's lock
as we the government is violating basic human rights again oh sweet man made
horrors beyond my comprehension we would also like to thank her families and friends who
helped make this game possible made with unity this game is a work of fiction named characters
business places events incidents and anything is just pure fictitious titles used with permissions
of the estate of late sonia bro now or will bro how now bronco you did amazing even if you
didn't sleep at all literally i got one hour sleep before this stream i don't know how am i live right
now i'm breathing can i jump back into chapter five please i want to take down the woman
fictitious sure sure we lost so much social credit for this stream i just thought you should know
the concert's in an hour you're trolling right why are you saying it's in an hour
our ignorance is strength i'm a nation bird
yeah don't worry no concert yeah why don't you try and give me a damn heart attack
i'm gonna take you to bed right can i
oh it lets me replay day five i feel for it often
i don't think i have it in me to do it right now maybe we'll do it tomorrow it's like a
little bonus end and i'm very tired right now right let me redirect into emmer's okay
let me go get my emmer's okay please go sweep yes i i was like oh i'm really excited to do it
but i saw it and i was like oh i'm so tired is she doing a short caller it freaking stream
the funniest thing about letting the girls do their own like to their own devices
is coming on and being like oh my god what is going on she sure wants to well apparently we're
redirecting to a short caller thing i'm not at the end
all right please sleep i will lie down so you can lay your head on my chest
i get to listen to your heartbeat while i sleep is that fair is that deal what are we doing tomorrow
let me check what we are doing tomorrow yeah we are doing the velour collab so i have to actually
prepare for that because i need to give ac all the details i it'll be hosted on ac's channel
i think thank you for the stream no thank you for this thing
usual emmy just emmy shenanigans
usual emmy shenanigans you deserve a good rest and listen to all her heartbeat
we will ask your project into your dreams for you oh thank you how did we dream that something
was touching my stomach yesterday like when i had an actual sleep hopefully emmer will not be demonetised
i mean limited ads sure she always gets limited ads i'm used to it now
but demonetised i hope not that's our income source emmy came back from vacation and came
out selling in the fact all systems are popular by humans thank you for the stream no thank you
for the stream thank you for letting me be absolutely uh hey what what would you what's
wrong with the what's wrong with my hat come on if it's perfectly just imagine it was transparent
okay if it was transparent it's fine and then it gets a little tilted on the axis okay
when did that reefling get there he's always been you've always been tinfoil hatin with me
the entire stream uh shebe's also streaming Elden Ring i'll redirect emmy because she's
been away for ages and then emmy can redirect into sheepsters because sheepsters has been doing
endurance Elden Ring she's been doing fantastic on it honestly it will get a transparent yeah
yeah next time transport your newton right let me just let me just refresh marshmallow in case
there's anything that needs my immediate um uh let's just go ahead try and burp in my mouth
i'm gonna ram my meat down your throat
didn't didn't think it was going that way gonna be honest can't read the rest of that out loud
that was not where i thought that was going to go i thought that was a meme and i read it with
full confidence that was a meme um
nice journey it's curious of just issues with uwu market because i ordered a hoodie last month
and still haven't got i was unsure if i should ask you or call them uh uwu market handle other
thing but they make things custom order they don't waste like it's not like they do a big batch of
something um they make it like custom order so it does take a bit longer check your email
that you got from them now again i'm not uwu market i don't deal with any of the merch that's
kind of the the best part about uwu market is that we don't have to touch anything but they do
make everything custom order like i ordered my keychains i'm still waiting for them to come
but it's because they make it to order they don't make batches does that make sense the stream got
me through work have i radicalized you be honest um
i never thought you'd actually read that marshmallow but what to expect from a perfectly cute
what the fuck i'm paying up for you guys do you guys think help wild card something wild card for
you before i was gone i can't read any of these
i can't read any of these at like refunds are you guys okay do you need an audio in two weeks time
be honest
that's the review this camp i was wearing a tinfoil hat before already proof i'm on stream right now
you're on my chest are you playing on my chest
i need more skits my scotsman wait until i do my education stream that comes out next week
um well i never want to see you pigeon holding to a particular style i have to admit i'm a rather
submissive guy and i'm a big fan of the situation to come up with and your dominant over the
refunds or take charge of the situation but i do appreciate the other ones to come up with
my love streams i'm glad you enjoyed them remember we talked about war thunder and your dad well
well anyways a training manual can containing the specifications for a jet was published again
yeah my dad's sitting like oh yeah some lovely schematics very good yes yes
i sent you one that you can read on stream okay let's see let me refresh oh i got a few more
dear beloved cuddles we are so happy that you love us so much that you still choose to stream
despite papa cuddles visiting you but please we beg you do not sacrifice your sleeping health
just to stream to us and put on content army flin know that we love you and care about you
your health is much more important than an extra hour of audio content you're not just a content
machine but how i say thank you i believe in like thank you as not just me being like oh here's
the screenshot of a subscriber milestone and saying thank you no thank you like here's content
let's have fun like i literally recorded an audio of me sitting on my microphone over and over again
and i'm gonna upload it as a thank you like subscriber milestone thank you papa cousin will
be there for two weeks and we have all the time in the world now so enjoy the two weeks with
father-in-law and take care of yourself i will i will don't worry don't worry i was having an
off day anyway my dad's not taking me out anywhere today tomorrow i'm going out um
because i think we're going to go to another cafe or maybe a restaurant on time so enjoy your
tv don't worry about his refunds we'll still be here once your short weeks are over just like how
we're here with the insurance stream um one or two hours streams more than enough yeah
yeah you work hard enough as it is and you deserve a break as much as you can get love
briefly love everything yes i will ravage you with technical oh no i i can't say these parts
like why are you supposed to admit them oh my god that's right i love you i love you too little
reason stop it join just not say i love you so much thank you for the great stream oh did you
enjoy it i don't i don't know if it's the most popular stream but i enjoyed it i mean she this is
my kind of game if you got a maid cafe make them wear the cat no they're not gonna maid cafe
you know what okay i am gonna skedaddle i'm gonna fucking skedaddle um and embers is oh
me though me though so you know how you've got multiple vowels in your name that destroys any
semblance of me being able to appropriately uh say your name you know correctly so you're getting
me ra aww me ra aww thank you for the continued membership stay healthy is also a good way to
say thank you much love how dare you use my words and logic against me how dare you
um hey starney just curious to send a marshmallow list of ideas for gen two i will discuss all gen
two meming ideas in the gen two stream that's coming up starney you're not gonna make the
rifling word the maid outfit for the cafe are you would i i don't know if i would put you in a dress
i feel like i feel like if i put you in like those gray sweatpants that you see all the memes
are about i'll just put you in gray sweatpants apparently they're easy access i can't wait for
the hypnosis streams in the future i know they're going to be good aww me who needs to literally
write the script so i don't mess it up i know you're gonna love bring freaking us adi love you love
everything uh hi strongzers hi we flurrrr just like us that would be your name back in debut you
mentioned reading books about human nature and really enjoying them there's this game called
near otomathia and it's very strange sometimes it has an interesting perspective on humanity it's
an action game but some of the stories told might tickle your pickle it takes around 20 hours to
complete so is that two endurance rooms you're asking for back to back don't mind if i don't
i kill is also easy access night night no do i please no my name's bannish for looker or snooping
i kill a gray sweats black compression shirt and a nicotine patch on the forehead gray sweatpants
so she can see who goes to the back door near pks near is extremely long near tickles near
definitely tickles there you totally know her for the content is her name like to be i think
to be or not to be near it's four endings and needs like four placers no no i can't do that
i'm no cut out for that okay um probably dumb question but does the meta tag basically mean
that in the audio you the narrator are strongy meta tag means yes i'm strongy in that moment and
you're reefing in that moment meta means like so you know when i'm like oh the asmr booth or something
like that or like it's related to me being like a streamer towards you or that kind of meta behind
does that make sense hopefully that makes sense um she does have a really nice dumpy though
four main endings and 22 troll ones wait no there's no like fake i was wearing the tinfoil
hat skews thing over thanks i didn't edit it myself reeflings did it i just i just yanked it yanked
me now your tinfoil hat tell in his it's terrible sorry i'll just look in this direction even though
i can't see chat at all in this direction i'm just gonna i'm just gonna look oh i can look at you
at the corner of my eye hi there's an ending for each letter in the alphabet is that a joke
or is that real okay i'm looking at you from the corner of my eye to make the hats sit properly
okay all right reefing ah meta equals strongy strongy not character so you know how like i can be
like oh a giantess just absolutely swallows you whole like that's roughly but if it's meta it's me
you know does that make sense a girl love it's real but they're really joke endings and
anything between them right away okay okay you literally you're giving us a side item
i've seen when you've been put in in my marshmallow don't think i don't know it okay i'm actually
straining my eyes doing that i'm gonna redirect into me please say hello to her thank you for
hanging on my crazy game and tomorrow we are doing a collab on acce's channel which i need to
say um but i'll do it i'll do it as always i always pull through like come on i always pull through
um okay i see you goofy cool bit tomorrow get big stretch because i'm gonna bed
yeah i get to go to sleep i get to go to sleep on your tongue and listen to your heart
and listen to your tummy sound oh let's hope amy isn't doing anything bad right now
gee willikers i sure wonder what we're gonna redirect into it's a mystery let's find out
okay i see you goofy goober tomorrow love you love reeflings thank you for hanging out with me
i see tomorrow
okay that was a really loud one